he's threatening Brooke 65 okay now we
gotta calculate what does have side czar
getting a queen always taking the night
with check maui ah yeah yeah I don't
know what she's doing but either way no
eat oh my gosh what is really true baby
do like the dogs out get a queen I don't
know I feel like a dog right now
[Music]
[Applause]
Ches calm is about playing yeah I look
Matt s players travel from all over the
world to one of the smallest Isles in
the British Isles I don't know if that's
true let's redo it back to you it's
rather shiny how are you my lady
right are we there are we going young
Indian stars Niehaus Sauron and pregnant
not Prague the nandana Prague none on
dead pregnant on dinner pregnant under
Prague none andhe with only half of the
top six board surviving over a little
and I just call them Prague Prague none
none none death
Prague a nun yeah how am i how am i
standing like it keep going
[Laughter]
LOL like up everything okay back in back
in back it up huh as we begin i totally
mess we're gonna do it again but I'm
getting closer get closer one more time
one more time what's round 2 set okay I
don't like that stay on me um Grand
Master's and India's top player vision
on trying to fend 9 2700 s gave up 1/2
points in the I hope you're enjoying
this beautiful position for black from
the French I can't believe I'm saying
that oh we don't know blight yeah hey
everybody
that's a blooper I said white gets a big
attack I don't like what I'm doing we
got a restart I'm sorry for white but
the truth is black has equalized I still
don't like what I'm doing I'm sorry we
got to redo it tips about why this is
okay for black in the sense that we have
to do it again I was close I was close
what's that all right yeah lovely day
innit
okay I just want to get that we get set
for round three here in just a moment
restarting yeah so you don't have any
idea who's gonna win in round eight
either do you yeah well we're gonna find
out as the top players all near the top
of the standings that was really dumb
let's redo that in the final two games
who's gonna pull and play their best I
like the idea but I get up yeah but we
are gonna find out if it retail wait am
I still in the right position who will
find themselves alone atop the standings
when the chests calm Isle of Man
international comes to a close I don't
like this take let's do it again
well Maxime vache the grog gives young
my greens or where the young American
star continued to rise find out along
with others that we're gonna find out
about
hikaru yeah it's big win here and let's
restart when one of the letters we be
able to find out now round six of the
Chester come island four players in the
joint lead here and the Isle of Man in
the Isle of Man or attend here on or on
and on at
welcome to the Isle the Isle of Matt got
it nailed it what
and welcome to the second semi-final
match here of the 2018 speed chess
championship Grand Master Robert Hess
alongside me
Danny wrench and we are we're pumped
today is Hikaru Nakamura versus Levon
Aronian and let's dive right in quickly
to remind you that yesterday obviously
we said goodbye to young christophe Duda
who's kind of magical magical ride here
being an underdog pulling upsets went
went bye-bye but it led to a daily
question that we actually had obviously
Wesley so played phenomenally but it
made us wonder what would be the who
might be the next rising star that we
would invite next year and I think the
best place to go is to the community
when we have questions so get involved
today use the hashtags feet chest let us
know your thoughts on the next table
junior that we should invite
up-and-coming star but all right hey
Carlo break is a naughty car of Robert
hey car was on the line too but Robert
break us down what do we see here what
do the numbers tell us and and what do
we what do we have in store here well
Hikaru Nakamura has to be the favorite
considering his history and speed Chess
Championship he's only lost to Magnus
Carlsen the reigning world champion the
newly rechromed world champion and
birthday boy so 70% win probability for
Nakamura seems fair especially given the
one a minute one second increment
portion six to four in favor of Nakamura
think it's even not giving him enough
credit for his bullets rails and I mean
okay to be LaVon has also played very
well in in the bullet portion so far I
think and I think that his it's more a
testament to lavon's performance than it
is us not being aware everyone knows
what he car Nakamura is capable of a
bullet right but there you go go you
know so the segment probability there is
what what kind of maybe separates Hikaru
throughout there but the the look at the
path these guys took to get here has
been impressive on both sides Nakamura
+25 is he fond that was just you know
she has she had many good positions that
he admitted as much just things were
going his way that day against MVL
Maxine brush Telegraph +8 is so great
but look on the other side a running
destroyed Fabiana
I mean maybe still the surprise so far
of all the matchups in the bracket right
plus 14 against the world championship
challenger LaVon LaVon came to play that
day and then he also had a good time
playing giri +7 that's also a monstrous
score against a very worthy challenger
nothing like beating a nice
by seven points I think right I think
Anisha would agree with that
so you just hope that he's listening
opening listening right now so you can
start the trolling on Twitter let it
begin but there you see our two players
right above us a car Nakamura got the
headphones probably got some music rock
and already Levon Aronian also got some
nice sexy if I don't know those are
those bows what are though those are
those are nice-looking headphones
probably just noise cancelling though
I'm not sure what music Levon is
listening to books in the shelf without
he's now blocking yeah it doesn't seem
nearly as animated and kitty-kitty hiss
hiss we love that we love that twitch
you haven't seen that username in a
while thanks for being here thanks to
everybody that's with us already whether
you're on twitch or chest comm TV I
think we're in store for a really
exciting matchup today absolutely and we
are gonna be getting going here in just
a moment I think the games will begin
momentarily the players are set they are
ready I believe the car was in he's been
she's travelling right now not at his
normal home site there with the red wall
the infamous red wall behind her car not
come whereas he's become known for his
streaming right yeah I know LaVon is
also traveling with family unfortunately
he left panchak at home he said ponics
being disciplined right now for some
behavior that he didn't want to get into
but all right we have chess we have
liftoff I think Levon is gonna be
looking to challenge Chicago and as many
main lines as possible he's gonna I
think he needs to get a lead here in the
five minute and three minute or shion's
to have a chance to win this match yeah
we were discussing this yesterday that
Levon really needs to get off to a hot
start against a car because if you're
not up by two three games heading to the
bullet I don't think you could feel
particularly comfortable right we might
get a really exciting game yeah we're
already diving in here to something
that's pretty short look at Levon go
that leads to me me to believe that he's
either been preparing hard for this
match or this is some secret sauce
preparation that he's had and he karo
comes right back with the move Knight g5
and gives us our first vintage hit karo
in the wild sighting of the day that's a
car and I can warn number 7 ladies and
gentlemen hooking up to the shoulder
slightly questioning his opponents move
but also trying to recollect theory that
is what that look means right there yeah
you go already Queen h5 looks like a
good possibility for white pawn on h6
will be pinned you're hitting f7 I
wonder in their corner chives on the
board
I was gonna say I wonder Blackstone this
castle and ignorin and that's exactly
what LaVon does and Hikaru quickly
retreats the night met by a five so kind
of similar to yesterday in this census
we came really flying out of the gates
with Wesley so and young Christophe Duda
they both they both played very quickly
in Game one maybe even some nerves kind
of being worked out a little bit neither
side wanting to get down on time and so
uh LaVon I think from a practical point
of view knows that Hikaru is is just the
fat I mean the fastest chess player
especially online I think on the planet
and I think I wouldn't be surprised if
LaVon came came here ready to to try to
get an edge on the clock when possible
so look at this it's a car just bailing
out and Game one with a perpetual I
wonder if he'll play on because I don't
know he's gonna he's gonna think about
it let's see right now yeah he's gonna
take the draw interesting how quickly
that happened and there was draw by
repetition right just Dean age six
Quincy six yep but black just had too
much right even if you took on e6 it
omits a second pond right for the P so
it wasn't quite enough conversation for
a full piece right that's why well this
is a peaceful result peaceful result a
very quick peaceful result only not even
three full minutes in and we already
have a result on the board hey Goro
clearly bring in the energy today why
the fans love him they love his his the
way he just wears his emotions on his
sleeve and just lets you know how he's
feeling and right now he's bobbing his
head having a good time here kind of on
his home turf here at chess calm he's
just ready to play and whoa
quick shot 92 92 comes out of nowhere
the bishops spying at each other just
ivory on the bishop and I don't think
that's that big of a deal right you can
just take on d2 with probably the night
I guess and by taking on d2 with then we
actually decide which piece I want to
take with and he does take with the
night I think this is fine after we're
gonna see Bishop takes c3 and then rook
e1 and OH
nineteen point five is a threat yeah
okay he had a bishop back yeah I see the
g6 and so Hikaru has just sort of snuck
in and grabbed the bishop pair right um
and it's a very important bishop pair
here because the light squares could
come back to haunt Aronian that's why I
win Knight a four they'd say well you're
not gonna you stuck with the bishop not
stuck left with a bishop yeah because I
can always take on b6 and there it is so
that's what here oniy
and I think the Takara will probably
return the favor at someone with a
capture on e3 unless he thinks that
bringing the knight to h4 has some sort
of outside attacking chances but I don't
see how the Queen gets involved over
here on the Kings side so so I expect an
exchange on e3 to happen but all right
f6 that's an interesting way to get the
queen of all right if you can open up
the F I'll bring some heat over here to
have two then you may see this knight
stay on the board and try to be a useful
attacker mister before is a good
response for the exact reason right now
after pawn takes e5 I took with the
bishop and I will have an isolated pawn
on d4 but it's protected well protected
by the bishop yeah and well well locked
in himself there kind of an outpost
square and poking over there at the the
g7 square so a car will quickly playing
okay for him bouncing he's just bouncing
around he came to have fun today Levon
much more kind of stoic in his uh and
his look there I think Levon just just
maybe doesn't play as much online chess
- and right now he's you know he's here
- he's here - he's here to win chess
games right now so he's got the real
focus look yeah he's a very quick-witted
individual for those of you who don't
yeah I haven't heard him most things
that are said before the show starts
can't be said yeah on camera I think he
really cares about the SEC so much yeah
that despite that he's a back he's a
fun-loving guy and likes him to crack
jokes he's here to win this match yeah
we talked about this that you know in
the previous speech Chess Championships
he runs some rough pairings yeah where
he's bounced in the early rounds and
here he beat both Fabiana which is a
very tough first time penetrate him and
it's similarly dispatched Geary in a
very impressive manner yeah so he's been
in the speeches championship and you and
I got to spend some time with Levon not
just in the in the pre calls we do here
but actually at the Isle of Man just at
the end of October and we know that he
was he was pumped and excited at his
performance so far and excited at the
opportunity to take on Hikaru so this is
and I believe what Wesley said is true
that whoever gets past today's event
will probably be favored against him and
the finals not to say that Wesley isn't
playing very well right now obviously
was fantastic yesterday remind everybody
of the format we we get a lot of these
questions so we came up with the best
way to describe it for you this is the
format of the match you have 90 minutes
60 minutes and then 30 minutes but a
constantly running clock which you can
see right there above the analysis board
so the players competing against their
opponent but
also against the overall game clock
trying to have a lead before time runs
out in each of those portions and of
course this year's event has $50,000 on
the line
total prizes so um pretty fun stuff if
you happen to be tuning in to the
speeches championship for the first time
welcome all right 96 I like the way he
played this and now look at this I just
can't stop looking at his camera
I mean he's giving you things to look at
right that's what he does and rook takes
f3 as a potential idea here everyone
watch out for that if if white made some
random move not only is the e4 square
available for the night but if something
like this happens and black can quickly
bring pieces over here to the to the
King side that would be very dangerous
so Livan playing whoopty to c1 offering
an exchange but I do like the tempo of
this game for record he's being extra
innovative today he knows what he's
doing he's giving us gift right of pay
attention to the board break he's
heading back to his camera because it's
so funny but okay so black is clearly
better here has more space to work with
but it's one of those positions that yes
you have to consider your sacrifice
right it takes to f3 I don't think
you've enough firepower remaining to get
away especially with those rooks on the
floor so even though he car what kind of
scowl dad I think that was lavon's idea
to get some pieces off the board to make
an exchange sack less likely so the
question is then Robert do you want your
nighttime c-44 or Bishop on e4 first
good question I think Bishop before will
be just met by night - D - ok followed
by pawn f3 so ok 94-94 instead sort of
pins the night because you know the rook
and Knight are both ganging up on that
poor little or a little Freddie on f2
look at him go Bishop h5 and now he's
forcing the night away but is there an
f2 native - Rick when we have night d1
at the end look at this Knight f2 rook F
191 putting the knight on a square that
normally doesn't venture - and that
might be good enough but then there's
even moves like Queen to b3 because if
you trade the Knights still trapped and
I'm threatening things like g4 dive
Queen h4 there and I'm trying to get
aggressive
Wow well Hikaru believes believes in you
Robert and he thinks he can go for this
Livan quickly responding with Queen XI 3
Bishop g6 of course that way it protects
the d3 in love - shook his head he was
not
expecting that movie just overlooked it
and he still has good chances to hold
this game because I would go rook F 1
here I guess but now an ID 3 is a really
annoying point if you had 94 and trade
the Knights then it's obstacle or Bishop
position right more comfortable yeah you
be you'd be feeling decent about your
drawing chances if we get out Skoda
bishops but 93 is a chance for Ricardo
to eliminate this very strong piece
that's hitting g7 yeah and maybe you can
maybe have to work up for 93 you can
throw in Bishop c7 and that might be
sort of a saving move but it's not
looking very pleasant for white here
because you're finding kind of these
last-ditch efforts just to stay in the
game rather than actually right you're
hoping to push you know not be down
material you're hoping to get a decent
chance to draw on the endgame but hey
karo definitely was correct I think in
gobbling that pawn on f2 so if you're
just joining us critical tactic happened
here in the game when a car built up the
pressure here against poor little
Freddie and then won that pawn when
Levon played 92 kind of calling his
bluff
and now lavon's got something to figure
out yeah it's one of those instances
where you don't want to expose your king
side but playing with like g4 earlier
right let's probably move that he should
have played so yeah sort of be caution
on a move like Bishop h5 even okay well
we are sitting here waiting for Levon to
make a move and now he's about to cross
under the minute line and this is the
reason why Hikaru is so dangerous in
this format it's not just that the chess
moves are coming and they're good but
but the speed of which they're coming
right and right now that that time
advantage right there is is a big one
we've got chess chess pays breaking down
Hikaru's music shout-out to chess pay
the one the only the lovely chess pay
thanks for being with us thanks to all
of our mods of course and those who are
actively in the chest community but but
there we go I love that who let the dogs
out Queen bon jovi ABBA
and I am missing the top one darude
sandstorm okay I think that's that's
like one of her carros kind of indie
favorites I've never heard of darude
sandstorm maybe that makes me a total
idiot but that wouldn't be surprising I
don't know but I've never heard of
darude sandstorm you heard of no okay
well there you go
loving the breakdown there and plus I
just love pie charts because I'm always
hungry
but you just love me are you really
talking to me about how exactly I
haven't eaten today hungry
Desert Storm Karl sorry on everybody
banana bread
thanks everyone is at the chest TV chat
we see you two over there thanks for
being here look at that move Knight to
c4 kind of a fork on the bishop at night
because I was gonna say white really
doesn't want to take there and give hit
car with this pass palm but he kind of
had to write people are mad about the
sandstorm thing that I don't know just
read out alive in the 90s I mean I was
born and I was born in in the 80s so I
was technically a 90s kid as far as a
lot of things I remember and I you know
I'm open to to learning about a new
artist that I guess somehow slipped my
slipped my attention so all right well
the chess back to back to the chest okie
5 and c4 it's also if only b5 a c4
existed I think black would still be
better right but now suppose b7 and
Slade's might be quite the inchworm here
look at that move d5 kind of desperate
by LaVon but he's trying to open up this
diagonal she's extremely smart yeah so
the bishop can stay on both g7 and guard
the passed pawns everyone that let's say
again so it is just a desperate pawn
sacrifice but a really creative idea as
as Roberts saying because it opens up a
much better coordination for the pieces
try to blockade and I was gonna say
you've highlighted an ops code Bishop
endings this extra pawn is not gonna
make a difference right either gonna
lose or not based on your ability to
hold maybe keep pressure on the dark
squares while this guy watches but
you're not gonna lose because of one
extra pawn so that's why it works and
right now white is down what three pawns
but it's one if you took the Queen's off
they're actually still are pretty good
drawing chance yeah yeah if you take the
Queen's off and White's King is not
worried about getting checkmated this
dark square Bishop is doing everything
it needs to do to keep the pawns
blockaded so look at the vine just
trying to sit on the position and here
comes Queen g40 I'll do that you gotta
call that you have to run and allow the
Queen trade yeah he's not afraid of the
Queen Jean look a look at a car trying
to evaluate yeah he couldn't what Queen
a five track and trade the Queen's but
he's not sure if he should
yep so instead he's trying to keep a
mating net going look at this this is
actually a brilliant little idea LaVon
is running the King to the Queen side
and now the car may be regretting that
he didn't trade Queens cuz how is this
queen ever gonna leave that she
so queen of fates a sneaky move because
not only does it it's not King c3 but
after Queen f8 you can go b4 and try to
trade off the pawns on that squad ah
interesting idea Carter didn't see that
he played Bishop before he'll go there
eventually I feel like was Queen of fate
now he's shuffling there doesn't see
this idea where he's got another one
here he's got a different one he's
trying to bring the king up no he's
gonna do he's gonna sack g7 and try to
run the King up I don't know how to do
it but that might be what he's thinking
I still love your idea of Queen f7 Queen
and fate but I I think at this point we
can say if you say hey carve doesn't see
this idea yet yeah I'll say LaVon leaves
four seconds left so maybe I'm just
trying to play quick moves to catch him
off guard and again the reason we like
this idea is that when you're hitting
this the point is if the king stays on
this diagonal now you can play before
and white can never take as the Queen
comes in which is one second left just
over one second living on the increment
living on the increment Oh Andy check 24
check traits Queens maybe he Carter
takes it now but when they takes the
deep honor that's just sort of my idea
but actually don't think that works
either because this opposite color
bishop dynamic means that that's a car
Oh number eleven right they're often
confused with number seven but actually
almost Queenie four takes to the Pawnee
can just bring his king to the G
Foursquare potentially where the H four
pawn feels very iffy so uh he's
calculating it now but I think he's
still just keeping the pieces on the
board I think partly just trying to take
advantage of the time but one second one
isn't flagged completely under time oh
wait how is point four he got the time
back buddy and now he finally runs out
of time how is it possible
can't have point four seconds left in
any move that's actually a great point I
have no idea what just happened there he
had point four seconds left after
getting a second back
question marks the math doesn't I mean
we know it's not my strong suit but no
it doesn't add up you're right but okay
hey Carlos strikes first and I think
that this this idea of keeping the
Queens on the board ultimately paid off
for because the hardest thing for LaVon
to think about under time pressure was
all the potential mating tricks yeah and
so the fact that Hikaru kept those
threats alive
showed why he's why he's so good in
these formats and there we see an image
of a car who will be
playing for the Seattle sluggers in the
pro chess league starting on January 8th
so good reminder of that look at the
card going right back to it and is he
gonna go no he does not now take on aged
64 just joining us game 1 actually ended
very quickly in a draw look at the
analysis board hit card Oh took on h6
played queen g6 and then to our kind of
surprise just it ended so quickly
instead of going for anything he just
accepted the professional took a draw
but here Robert he's repeated that line
but not the idea of a perpetual he's
saying that I'll be a pawn down but look
at the dark squares sorry only I'm
dealing with dark square Bishop you put
your 9 c6 is just played just to keep
control over the e5 square but White's
attack looks like it might come pretty
quickly now black should play Bishop d7
I try to go to e8 and that's another
defender up on the King side yeah buck
g3 is coming at some point soon plus the
the battery on e6 makes this hard to do
yeah and your rook and Bishop can't
share the square right you would love to
have your rook and Bishop on e8 but
that's not happening
shout out to HP for three you also
donated yesterday thank you for your
support buddy glad you're liking the
show
alright sees put the bishop when I have
seven that's the plan Queen Queen might
even come all the way back to d1 here
right yeah keep an idea of swinging over
to the Queen side if you need to yeah I
guess no matter what LaVon is gonna play
Bishop f7 just to safe guard the e6
square and me do play for g5 honestly
because if you're leaving the King side
that's a good point in fact I love this
move well not yeah I know I wish I could
do it right away but II six is falling
what's the point seven then go fishin
here comes g5 the carto taking its time
to think about that one and here we see
the Vaughn getting a time edge for one
of the first times in the match which I
think again is something he'll need to
do consistently well King h8 was not as
not explore Oh Sees bishop on mr loves
it loves it he caught appeared in now
he's shaking his head telling us he
doesn't believe that his opponent as the
would take on e7 maybe just about ninety
seven group g6 Knight takes g6 and
saying I do love Queen sex is definitely
the best way to go about this because
especially in a blitz game you have a
knight over one pawn it's Lasker
compensation that's yeah the term is
lookin out the old velasca reference oh
yeah loves it and and you've got a
target yeah
right white lacks the target so again
regardless of the mathematical
evaluation this is a position that is
very tricky for white and I think you
and I have often said in this format the
Queen is just such a beast and we think
that over time it's always hard to
compete with with the Queen and in rapid
and blitz but but objectively I think
black is doing okay here yeah actually
you know I think white is certainly
better but black is a clear plan yeah
actually it's not very clear what white
is going to do because black setup
despite the ugly bish 107 is very solid
or you know II 6 d5 f5 setup that limits
the bish mundi 3 so it's not like that
bishops doing so great all right and
then I don't you 6 at some point can
reroute it right it can be read itself
to f6 maybe even okay you don't
necessarily want to keep the knight on
the board you're not looking for a
square like e4 here but that's a smart
move by a karo because if we're looking
to learn from these games everybody you
want to open up the position for the
Queen so she can quickly spy targets on
both sides of the board extremely smart
by LaVon to not trade the rooks that d4
pawn can become a target right there's
no pawn protecting it so instead of
trading Brooks and making a cars life a
little bit easier
he's now flipping from the C file to the
key file and watch out for a 5 I did I
was gonna say Plus even though I doubted
her car opening the position which I
know we would agree is good for the
Queen it also opened up this square on
d5 for the night as well so there's all
kinds of things that LaVon has going for
him in this position despite swiping
down as Queen so you got a calculate e 5
and I guess it doesn't work as bishop
takes F 5 comes back and now you're
rockin T sevens also hanging okay again
that if I move at some point is gonna be
very tempting LaVon quickly plays the
other rook to d8 and again I think the
time is indicative to of the fact that
he Caro knows this is harder than it
looks this is not easy for him to find
the right plan for the Queen against the
pieces right I think the one should just
play ace just instance here right the
position is so comfy cozy for black and
he's up a minute on the clock
yeah and ease of them in the clock I see
this Knight relocating itself to d5 I
don't know I see just the pressure on d4
making it very hard for white to ever
focus on anything else in here here
come's LaVon with that plan yeah cuz me
likey because the card should I put the
bishop on B three and hit a six but a
ninety five blockades that yeah but I
still like that because I like a knight
on the board you made screen to c6 yeah
in 2d 4.0 I mean keeping the knight on
the board is really the one piece that
white lacks here right so if you can if
you can just keep
that night bouncing around make white
slave driver work here he 5.65 in there
was rook t1 check as a possibility so he
didn't go for it yeah that would have
been interesting
we had a discovery there everybody in
Roberts eyes are quick despite all of
this happening LaVon may have had this
between c5 at the end all down double
attack for chemo crazy look at a car go
d5 that's a nice defensive sacrifice
because if you're gonna lose that pawn
try to break up black structure you're
trying to open up things for the Queen
again that's what you have to do in
these types of positions but that palm I
just start becoming a passer d4 here
keep it going yeah this is double edged
and now black is I love blacks black
isn't running with the deep one
yeah that's not an easy pawn to stop
because now a trade bishop son b3 which
means you don't have a cover for the d1
jailer honestly if what LaVon wins this
game this may go down as one of the best
games in the match because this is a
really really instructive display of how
you can use the pieces to outplay a
queen and prevent her from getting
targets ninety five here just give up
that okay rook d5 similar Katja take on
that five you trade the D pawn D pawn is
dirty dirty Darrell as they say did they
say that not that I know they do now is
it so h g5 yeah we look at five would
come so you gotta take first yep pawn g4
h d4 and then g5 is certainly a
possibility here because your G for pawn
on g4 h g4 g5 even just playing d3 just
getting that pawn one step closer is
gonna really give this Queen headaches
you never want your Queen the most
powerful piece to be blockading upon
never I just not ideal and that's
exactly where she's at right now she
can't do anything but worry about dirty
Darrell over here maybe my boy Daryl's
watching shout out to Daryl Daryl Morey
I know you're watching this buddy not
that you're dirty in any way yeah I just
dare also the only Darrell I know he's
literally the only Daryl I know oh can I
call you Darrell no okay absolute not
you're Darryl Strawberry yeah that's
true I do Darryl Strawberry you all
right King G to bring the rook to to the
C file get in on c2 that's it that's
gonna help
Errol run Rick c5 is a very 10 I also
like this move Knight g6 if we're gonna
flip flip things around and maybe try to
make the
target as well but perhaps better just
to remain all in with the deep on rather
than looking to get things against the
king what do you think yeah that's him
honestly a five is another movie that
comes to mind saying that pawn on b3
might quickly become a target if I got a
five and rook b5 you know there's win
that pump I definitely like rooks even
if you create a second passer exactly
try to go make make an a poly
yeah so that would be and I mean black
is as many different options here and
Lev is up on the clock okay it's about
to be level in the clock but very good
time mentioned as far by him sacrificing
the Queen when you sort of had to I
think he sort of stumbled into it more
so than planned it right but still it
was a very good decision at the moment
look at a car he's not comfortable here
because well he's worse right he may not
be come from that shirt I didn't want to
talk to him about plaid yeah you don't
want to wear plaid on the big screen so
you're saying I don't know I just I'm
not sure about the style today
all right rookie for rook c5 is a
response okay I do like this move cuz
this g5 score being so protected you
know again I wasn't sure we should go
after the king when we have the D pawn
with all our hopes but if you can
balance threats by the D pawn against
the white king that's also gonna make a
Karl's life difficult but don't you
always say you want to pawn on g5 if
you're gonna put your 9 g6 right Knight
yeah that's why
look at him trading off the set of rooks
now
if he does I don't see an immediate
follow-up but he's one move away from
just you know if this knight can just
get into a squared we're gonna have a
new lady baby girl on d1 yes um I don't
know how you avoid that trick is rookie
2 is the response if you move that rook
to say right rook goes anywhere else
here comes rookie to now you've still
got the king to worry about and the D
pawn so I think Hikaru's gonna have to
trade and indeed he does an f4 f4
wowzers you kick that night away so okay
and this is where it's gonna get tough
cuz now the both sides under time
pressure despite how good LaVon has
played we know what happens when the
Queen right the Queen is just so much
easier to play with when you don't have
before claws protect that pawn or night
before so good oh so good but I don't
know if it's enough because the King
will sit on d1 that Queen will get right
issue that's that's why this idea by
Hikaru is so good because if you can
free the Queen to do what she does best
get out here and create chaos yep
that's where the Queen will outplay the
knight and Brooke and so a brilliant
point all of this please take me on d3
because Neelu is your queen
to cookie for criminy mode one by show
me your PIN emotes chat we love it Wow
so where's where does a car go I guess
he wants to go gee [__] there it is
and that g5 home be nice now I like say
oh I wanted rook h4 I wanted to swing
around for mating Nets okay hey Carlos
stopping that now don't play Brooke cage
for you'll lose it we have to charity
Utley and this is getting tricky because
actually queen of three check is a
threat winning the pond so each so you
had to play Brooke t4 yep and said also
that pawn g5 and some lights goes too
far right if you right if you a g6 check
I'll go key f6 and you're gonna have a
hard time keeping that pawn on the board
yep I'm gonna Jesus play King of six and
now the issue is don't play 95 because
Queen up two doesn't actually work
ninety-five might be a good move you can
take the Rooker's of a fork I'm not sure
if he saw that fork emotes look at this
new karo has yesterday he can't take the
the rook wow what a nice tactic I'm not
sure LaVon saw that and Knights are
super tricky and well in general but
especially in blitz games he's just
gonna rip back I think they should go 95
now see it the second time around well I
wonder if b7 is hanging that's what he's
more concerned about a good point right
95 takes b7 Queen's gonna get frisky out
there and they actually just agreed to a
draw which I don't really hold against
LaVon because he was getting under time
pressure you're feeling nervous about
what the Queen can do to you when you
don't have time to worry about all those
little crossfire checks so his best
opportunities are also behind it Mike
Warren yes started the past pony the two
rooks in the night versus one work that
was really and the Queen that was really
where he was going
yeah playing for win good realization
you don't want to go overboard you're
only down one game he's not very early
to match right you're not in any kind of
must win scenario right yeah but that
was that was a really interesting game
if we keep getting dynamic just like
that we're in for a treat today yep
we're also in for in for some Twitter
action the daily question today was
asking you what young up-and-coming
superstar you would like us to invite
next year given that we had the sad
moment of young christophe Duda his his
Cinderella story here in this vgs
championship came to an end yesterday
but he still has a very bright future
so what other young players you want
look at that I'll answer the question a
second I just look at this game I came
in nuts White's not a piece but yeah I
mean the see how Sauron is one of the
recommendations and bruza yeah because
the Knights coming to e3 I comes to e3
and then we have take on e3 cuz after on
take on e3 we opened the rook this feels
like lavon's game this has to be right
because you're just yeah this is an
attack that's about to get nasty alright
so he went Knight to be eight so can I
go Queen g3 chats a nice move by the way
to come around to d7 and try to defend
f6 oh good move by a Caro he Bob's his
head cuz he knows it right he's happy
with the movie it's played but it has to
be something here right it seems super
dangerous like what you want to do is
you just want to get this rook on the F
file though how do you do it right now I
was thinking of you a queen g3 check
King h7 than f4 but then there's some
Brook g8 yeah I'm not really sure what's
going and you've you've created tactical
consequences for yourself you might have
to deal with things like Knight g4
exactly right and and this is a is a
real real problem so LaVon has some
things to think about yeah and again if
you want to get involved on Twitter we
went away from that but please let us
know your thoughts there's always the
obvious answer D House are in the
country men of prog nandana right now
make him say oh sorry I cannot not know
it just makes me want to rap I wonder
what his rap name would be if he was a
gangster rapper prog no Emma don't ask
me you're the one who comes up with
these kind of crazy food for thought I
just have to put up with them King H one
on on f4 is the goal that's why you put
the King on that square but out of cars
he just keeps crunching his face
questioning the moves yeah
now the knight could come to f5 by the
way because in this position as much as
you traded a piece it's not easy for
black to get rid of that Queen and here
comes that for right definitely
something you can consider I guess I'd
have to move the Queen then move your
night away from f6 and hope that you're
surprised I like that ya like that idea
do you have to take I feel like you
probably do but maybe you don't take
quite yet can you start with King h7
yeah that was sneaky by Hikaru sneaky
I'm very worried for Livan Livan of
course okay here's my Queen h3 I'm
threatening to take and then shake and
bake on age six yep followed by
discovered checks Bishop g5 immediately
just yeah very good point so just to
show you Aflac make some random move we
got all kinds of nastiness coming over
here I think oh no we I was gonna bout
to say we're gonna see Queenie but he
plays g4 I think he's just hoping that
because I just wanted me to use my emote
sorry whoa I'll get you for that off and
go ahead this Knight takes h6 oh he just
went with a sac right away saying that
if the King takes on h6 the big problem
is after King age six g5 check you can't
keep sacrificing because look at this
king that King would end up on g5 and if
your Kings on g5 you're too asking to
get checkmate Lite LG g4 always works
g4 always works so Hikaru's now deep in
thought here on taking his first kind of
relaxed pose of the day really that a
chess bookshelf or like a other
literature bookshelf if I'd if I had to
guess no he live on but um Wow but this
has been a nice attacking game in a ton
of dynamics yesterday I feel like the
excitement is real I mean the promised
us said we're not gonna get twelve
dropping right he did and we've had
we've had Queen sax and nice mating
attacks and inadvertent rhyme times and
we're all here together so thank you for
being with us whether you're at twitch
or chest comm TV don't go anywhere
before you hit a follow button and keep
following this channel for the biggest
events in chess all right Knight takes
h6r thinking with his ear as you know
well what's your car look is this yeah
that was number 11 okay number 11 is a
general a general again it gets confused
with number seven number seven happens
early in the opening stage because he's
trying to remember theory number eleven
he is like skeptical and end but also a
little bit nervous yeah he's he's
skeptical that's actually that's
actually a mixed breed right there that
was a mixed breed so on hikaru
I wonder if you could hear real what are
we doing over
he's so good at playing to the crowd
someone sit on in taking a swig of vodka
I don't nothing but onions not playing
here or maybe there with Vichy I don't
think Commission would do that right no
I don't think Vichy drinks alcohol so
your chess player is correct here no
okay so this night is still hanging on
aged six
but King takes h6g five check is the
huge concern you don't want to allow
after King aged six g5 checked just to
move your King back cousin after pawn
takes no matter where you go this was a
happy happy moment for a white stream
there although if the King runs all the
way out one and your Kings are probably
too far okay so I can't I can't take and
play King he ate Knight of faith that
was my I was seeing how far I could get
you can I don't know how I'm like
Forrest this is actually pretty direct
rook GA check I think queen h5
threatening oh and I can't even get
there cuz f7 is falling okay you win
chorus forest falls short
sometimes just got to keep on running
though when you got a king here in
trouble though a car was gonna be
calculating some lines like that even if
he doesn't go for but look at the time
look at LaVon
yep bringing the tempo bringing the heat
right not gonna get down on time against
the infamous legend that is a card
that's what I love about LaVon style
he's not afraid of anyone so people
would play in a speech s matching scar
say oh he knows tactics better than I do
I'm not gonna play this type of chess
exactly but let's I'm a coffeehouse
tactician himself as he said you know
he's uh he's always looking for a
swindle right like a squirrel
looking for a swindle no no chickens
here no chicken moves no way he may he
may play chicken moves later but so far
no LaVon is not bringing the chicken
move but if he does we will call him out
for it oh look at this G function it's
happening it's on the board here we go
by that I mean we don't have an engine
but that evaluation mark he's going up
and down it's making me a little
nauseous
yeah a little seasick yeah think of it
ginger pills
pick a car his face he's so frustrated
okay he doesn't want to do this but he's
gonna have to you have to hold on for
one more day
yeah this is gonna be so scary for a
furry faces dark akaru if you take g5
ride the dark side Anakin look how is
this king escaping okay so Bishop g5
yeah takes rooked you one check or a
very direct sequence I think we're just
mating or winging age six
you can't beat the shaft of this yep
like okay cool Queen III is a bishop on
a seven yeah I was gonna say you gotta
that's my hole right here have your
Wheaties but but okay I think the attack
is still very very strong even just like
a rook lifts
there it is Ritchie yeah I like this
move oh that was a huge blunder like me
and Levon or synchro's synchronicities
today telekinesis Holmes it's real
that's a word look it up okay so what is
the idea now here comes rook g3 the
rooks gonna swing over the Knights
coming to g6 may work g1 96 Queen f5 put
pressure one thing she seems clean a5 I
love it in fact let's show it because
one of the threats behind Queen of five
is rook takes c6 and and mate right
there that is the threat that is the
fret so rook comes to g1 Queen of five
hey Cara go run what
but can he survive look at the
confidence so Ruchi six I mean that's
one Saul Lynn he's gotta prove it he's
down to minor pieces so Queen takes g6
King here done winged g7 and rook cheese
so like with h6 also nice rook g7 and
there's threats ah and Hikaru knows he
blew it
although the threat is Queen h8 Queen e7
yep as his about to say because if we
knock returns Levon and the one takes a
deep breath and frustration he knows the
car is not gonna get made it just yet
know what you can do for for LaVon is go
rook takes g7 Queen g7 check and yeah
just start stealing all the Queen side
pawns who takes these seven King Jesus
when she's seven king of chopped Alicia
Bishop f2 really is crazy and even
though the the black black has a lot of
pieces the Queen that getting pawns and
the King being open
typically very games but after Queen b7
let's say then Brooke g8 both Kings are
do I get made it I might you're gonna
move that h-bomb yeah this is these the
kind of things LaVon us to calculate now
he will have the Queen this time when
they're in the time scramble unlike the
previous game so can you just somehow
sit on the position for a little bit I
don't I guess there's enough time but I
think that Queen g6 check
because you can't go King D seven quid
you sick sick Kings that would be huge
blunder cuz Queen takes f6 first right
that would be a big problem for black
yep
B for plain look at it just playing calm
chess sitting tight cuz the Queen's not
going anywhere okay but if Carla's gonna
go get a pawn the Vaughan kind of nods
his head and understanded agreement whoa
III a move
oh no Queen g6 check still I guess okay
but I like lavon's idea cuz he's saying
when I do get your queen now my Kings
not gonna be animating net right that's
what he's doing he's gone for c7 now and
the King will run out will no longer see
rook g8 with mating ideas on she want
but e force hanging right now okay he
doesn't take it here it comes
g8 King runs to f1 just need to go to F
once at f3 I guess he just didn't want
to get the King don't point him walking
closer to the night I guess I like the
move c5 gotta play king E - I'm pressure
is real here though okay so what do you
do just take or be 5 Queen a 6 check
first I like that I like that even
better and so does LaVon
now you can give another check or take
because if Bishop takes wait it's but
black is definitely better here I
thought maybe he could have played Queen
a7 and then push but his black has two
minor pieces and a rook or a queen and a
pawn that pawn is great wow that's a
risky move there Queen d5 I would have
looked to push a six Kings getting in a
mating net this is nice e5 check
I feel like Hikaru is is gonna spot a
mating it here and teach us what it's
all about
rook c5 c5 also Brooke c1 yeah ooh
knife six was not expecting that in e6 I
love how well the knight protects the
King from checks by the Queen starting
every square making it so tricky for the
Queen Bishop c5 just wins the Queen
nobody use take it and then you take it
you can't stop the a pond or a canyon
you get the Knight to d6 you know a pawn
time there you take with Chuck Inglish
and then you had ninety six and a seven
and then ninety eight 8 equals Queen
it's Jack the Kings on b6 wide open
working on b6 oh I didn't know what I
was calculating the line gotcha I gotcha
we're
I shouldn't be doing that in my head but
I was very away well we we just want to
way down the rabbit hole there is
someone gonna escape with a perpetual
he's gonna try he's gonna escape a seven
he's laughing in the face of Maine's
king he made it it was like oh that's
heartbreaking
I was howie's how he's that was I was
sure I made a car is feeling very
relieved there because this King wasn't
some big trouble what a turnaround by
the way if you're just joining us now
that may end up being the game the game
of the match right there it's hard to
imagine the chess is gonna get any
better today we're gonna keep saying
that but it's awesome because we have
two really really exciting players LaVon
just went for a brilliant mating attack
hikaru somehow defends his way out of
that and goes on to actually prove the
Queen sacrifices is all is more than
enough to win in the end game amazing I
promise you this will not be the game of
the manage this game will not this is
looking like LaVon wants to take his
foot off the gas a little bit and get
something a little more symmetrical
there you have our two our two players
that everyone and then the past they
took to get here or you believe the two
most dominant players in the 2018 speech
Chess Championship isn't even an
argument I don't think so I think
they've been the two most dominant the
reason they're here in the semi-finals
with amazing amazing performances
against the players they beat to get
here so you're just joining us thanks
for being here don't go anywhere we got
a few hours of exciting chess ahead just
drop some chess knowledge here this
reminds me and it might be the same as
sokar wanna see [__] up 2016 and so is
half man that that game was so Caruana
it was so Caruana yeah this looks very
familiar to me now pretty sure that's
what stemming from but slightly slightly
slightly better for white no real risk
but black should be holding with best
play LaVon clearly knowing this line
very well playing very quickly a car
doesn't seem so thrilled does position
with the white pieces
yeah it's headed headed for a draw
perhaps simplification killed the hikaru
winning chances yep just so funny you
just gotta love it I mean the car was
channel at which by the way you can go
to twitch.tv slash GM Hikaru and give
him a follow
but his uh feel like his channel doesn't
need to be anything but his
numerous his numerous facial expressions
yeah you know you could just call it
make our own number one in car number
seven car number eleven this is a draw
number three and this is what I'm
estimating in this game because okay why
is pushing a little bit quicker than
black is but after this Bishop trade it
looks one thing your car can do it from
a strategy we're gonna ask him about
this out rewards but I get I get this
feeling he's gonna settle in here and
play this one out taking some time off
the total game clock because again
Hikaru knows that as as the time
controls speed up he just becomes even
more of a monster right and so yes this
is a game there should be a draw but if
this if this takes another you know ten
minutes off that total game clock you
see there between the players just gets
him even closer to three minutes yes I
just I have to find out laughing all day
I love it anything you said cuz I agree
with you but his facial expression so
priceless yeah
and he questioned lavon's decision take
on e6 and do this with the Queen
co-starring Queen d8 checkmate and the
pawn a7 but LaVon laughs at this idea
just take a sip yeah he's gonna go Queen
d3 check back then he'll then he'll deal
with the Palmer here probably g6 we see
here okay I was wrong so it karo not
interested in milking the game clock the
total match clock accepts the the
opportunity for a quick draw there we
have a another fan getting involved here
in the teaming question maybe you could
have a young stars qualifier tournament
whoa what a great is the idea a great
idea somebody get Michael on the phone
our twitch chess program we need to
let's make a note of that so I don't
forget it seriously because I think
we've already been talking about
improving and adding some some dynamic
and some more prizes to two more
qualifier events next year and I think
that's a great theme or one specific
qualifier all about the world's top
junior so thank you for that great great
idea and we had qualifiers this year we
had an open qualifier then we did have a
qualifier where we invited four very
well-known strong grandmasters but I
love that idea but that would be a great
angle to let the let the juniors tell us
who deserves to be there yeah
exciting surprise no one mentioned the
Russian player artemyev one of the big
up-and-comers you have 21 years old
maximum so I guess it's the Hekla Junior
but still but you get an invite yeah
Geoffrey I'll be the Oprah of invites
everyone gets anyway okay so we have a
similar looking position as we had
earlier except the difference is White
has not sacrificed a piece on g5 right
all right she wasn't redone the g5
square was f3 square but still point
being there's no peace sacrifice here
yet white is very solid in the center
black claiming that the spatial grab and
the kingside is actually good for him
that's a car then I can come to have for
at any moment the f5 square looks weak
what's hard to actually get to because
the British 26 will sit there if you
take on e6 I think with the pawn I love
that love that taken with the pawn just
visualize that right there open a file
guarding the critical squares it's a
trade you don't want to make and so
seasick so can i I can't go d4 I don't
have enough he's defending this square
have you know three you're still gonna
try to I that f5 square as long as you
can but this is a very typical approach
for black in this kind of structure for
those of you who are thinking wait I'm
not supposed to open up my own King
because black can quickly get so many
minor pieces to this side of the board
it's not only something that works out
because the King has plenty of
protection but also gets really
aggressive at times because Knights work
out so well behind pawns right so this
is a typical approach for black against
this kind of Italian structure and we've
now we've now seen it twice even though
the last time we saw it was a piece XO
I'm liking the approach for mcaro and
again up about a minute on the clock
he's got great flexibility in his
position you know d5 right now if he
wants to give out h5 HR looks very
tempting as you're mentioning but I can
start an attack on the King side
h5 threatens to win a piece immediately
with h4 and how do you challenge that
okay please b5 I'm not sure I love that
because opening the a file everyone
anyone wasn't doing anything and sure
loves it the rook on a wasn't doing much
either but I think this gives white a
little bit of counter play that's a rare
one that's a car number 23 the duck lips
[Laughter]
oh my garage a gold member there was his
name Steffi 94 says looks like a Ronnie
wasn't doing great without I her support
I think
now I'm here go LaVon him or her but so
I will let LaVon know that you're here
and he has permission to start winning
yeah he needs to start winning because
again heading toward the bullet section
that's where I'm most concerned about
him yep can't be facing any sort of
deficit you need a couple game leave a
car was looking like he you know I don't
know I call Phil Jackson up get some
peyote turn on some ABBA and have a ball
that's where we're headed with this
these dance moves
you just got to do surprise don't even
know what's today about his you know his
performance there's a nice move you know
finally freeing up that bishop yep oh
and Nikora says well I'm gonna let you
trade it before you go anywhere d3 is
hanging now so you can't just put Bishop
f2 like you'd like to and you don't
really want to go Knight d2 f1 but if it
defends the d3 square and then you can
reroute your Bishop to f2 and the play
Knight to g3 I like that is something
worth consideration yeah especially
because two nights here will mean you
can actually put a knight on f5 and keep
it there and that's that's a square that
Roberts been eyeing for some time but I
like the way black is progressing on
this other board as well because we
talked about h5h for for black certainly
still an idea yeah
interesting that's not the way I would
have protected the D pawn especially
with h5 and H for coming but LaVon maybe
has more plans on the Queen side than I
just hang upon ether he's hanging right
yeah take twice and then win d3 off at
f5 square so yeah he's making a
sacrifice a Caro also kind of skeptical
is all right D pawn 4f v square and I
don't know if I'd go for that if I'm a
Cara shout out to that abrogate your
support rook a7 yep
saying you know you're gonna take me an
e6 whether you like it or not because
I'm but just when they get get things
going over here on the a5 you're not
gonna have a choice taking any snip
there goes that pony 6 now the semi open
F I'll certainly favors black your 93
while it's on a good central looking
square not going anywhere with the f5
square and the D folks were firmly under
blacks control a very good transition or
head car he's think extremely well right
now very impressive chest from him yeah
we should honestly he's he's I mean the
two games that LaVon was the one
bringing the pressure not only did he
swing to live it he won one of them
right I mean just amazing stuff right
now for mokoro join why he is the best
in the business in this in this setting
I mean look at this he just wins by
resignation LaVon just hung upon
straight up and tired of that game
throws in the towel it was a second
pause Wow gave up oh you know I was
really looking forward to today because
I thought it'd be a pretty level match
at least before the bullet session yep
you know I can't lie the bullet part of
the match really slow there's no reason
why you wouldn't favor her car bullet
part of the match based on what we know
about these guys but right now hikaru is
it's bringing way more than just bullet
prowess to this match amazing stuff
three game lead car yeah is it too early
to say it's an insurmountable lead oh
it's way too early
yeah and I think LaVon is a streaky
player so I think if and when he starts
getting his mojo going don't be
surprised if he's able to rattle off of
Hugh in a row okay I'm just testing you
yeah past you know steal more from you
thank you thank you there you go got a
net plus shout-out to everybody that's
with us no matter where you're watching
we love you we appreciate you hope
you're having fun hope you're looking
forward to the holidays yeah Roberts
looking forward to a break from me after
the World Championship in this Beach
Chess Championship yes
I'm this time I'm gonna hurt my own
feelings now I have intimacy issues I'm
gonna push you away before you can
reject me Wow truth at last
okay so different approach this time
last the same structure and lavon's
gonna put the bishop on e6 yeah and we
had a quick draw there unfortunately for
levy has to do more than and find
peaceful results in order to get back in
this thing yeah and you're the sole
difference as far as if there's a pair
books on the board so the last time all
the rows got traded now at least what
has control over this d-file Bishop e6
and you take with the Queen I'll maybe
make them look like on p3 and just keep
the default going that's really where
whites advantageous yep all the smiles
yeah
I would keep the rooks on the board a 6
or b3 okay
a3 or b3 I then sorry
he plays a three okay a thirty makes
sense you keep the Queen on c3 defendant
just in case something happens where you
know some kind of trade is offered yeah
and you don't have to work with your a2
poem because the B's DuPont is clearly
defended right now and so might be three
maybe loosened up some of the squares
over there on the Queen side so I think
it's a good choice all in all car is
just jamming loving it she's gonna rip
d6 and LaVon it's gonna say I don't care
too much
yep because I like Queen at five and
throwing back rank the long term edge
here belongs to LaVon if he could
somehow not let the D file lead to
access to the seventh rank maybe if he
can even get his own Brooke active it's
hard to see how he does that right now
which is why we like white now if this
rook can somehow find a file of his own
but the three-on-two should be a
majority the black can be able to use if
he can get the pawns going from as this
a pawn is so far advanced you also have
to watch out for shots like e6000 makes
perfect sense yeah there's this check
though gotta watch out for b2
yeah that is true such an F for a for
now he can play King h2 and then go back
to your idea right he also you know he's
thinking I was gonna I just like to do
it where's my emote g4g for everyone's
favorite oh sorry I was just given the
information that LaVon has never trailed
after the five in it plus one second
increment segment he he's been tidying
his crook once loves last year and he
got leading in the other three matches
he took pardon this if this segment ends
with the Carson Gris Chuck was two years
ago to you then he also played the palm
neo she in 2017 right and and then this
year he's young so he's never been
you've never been down in the
proportions I look at that is some chief
act classy moved by left yep undermining
the punch is ready to go a little
frustrating for a car there you can see
is that a yawn or back to the duck lips
is that no no he faked us out no hikaru
number 23
watch out for those duck lips they may
come back just so funny
okay look d6 h6 is falling c6
but if I yeah it's a trade to pawns for
two pawns and rookie - yeah you gotta
love this move
second rank and F Vaughan yeah if the f1
stays in the board Freddie's gonna
become Francis over here
yeah and blacks kings start running up
the board nice nice little reference
there takes e5 I think should be played
yeah - and we're expecting very concrete
lining yeah this looks good for love and
we called it ice sorry well her car play
rook f6 here just take this F pawn off
the board he's gone for the a pawn and
I'm mildly concerned about your saying
before but I like this mover I keep the
keep the b-pawn as a target now you can
trade and play rugby - I mean okay it
should be a draw
probably best play here should I - want
to with on opposite of the boys rook c4
yep I like that because that rookie fork
yeah and you have to trade h4f likely
cuz you don't want to play a three in
king of - oh that's interesting though
actually just winning both yeah cars
laughing because he just yeah he just
missed that move he's like uh uh that's
pretty funny it should still be a
Georgia spaceship on because on the
other side of the board white actually
has an extra pass pawn right you know
each bone is essentially an extra one
yeah as it double F pawns are not going
anywhere I can remember a lone wolf in
chess TV chess as Alexa what's the car
listening to I like it so let's see what
is can black even try to make go for win
somehow he's it pushed his a pawn down
the board so actually the Winnie plan
would be if that rook was on a1 and pawn
was on a - it would be a then you could
use the F pawn as a way to get the King
out of there you know I mean if it gets
close maybe we'll highlight that idea
cuz that's an instructive one for the
members shout out to grandmaster your
mullinski here hanging out in the chess
TV chat mo your mo so how does black and
Buck I don't see any project you you can
sit tight yeah I was gonna say get the
King in maybe try to put white in some
sort of time pressure scenario is you're
not even in a position I don't think Y
can take here in any any endgame any
universe the king will always be too far
too
the a pond Wow but they just agree to a
draw by mutual agreement d4 that was AB
I was going to say I was wondering when
love would switch to d4 yeah because
he's you know he's been playing me for a
lot as of late but for many many years
he was just pretty strictly a d4 player
and it's c4 yeah oh look at this
London set up we think about that okay
we saw lovely views this effectively in
previous speed chess matches right I
remember his matchup with nepo had a lot
of London yeah that was two years ago
but we had the call on that and not two
years ago I guess about a year ago but
army sync of London after that World
Championship but here the the opening
representing the city and the thing
about the London we will say is that
it's it's usually a set up that white
can play with a lot of flexibility you
can you can develop the pieces for an
attack you can also look to play on the
Queen side and your car taking kind of a
unique approach here with the knight on
age five but we've seen this happen in
lines where black can be ultra
aggressive early on before white
completes development here black see off
onto f5 because the bish 23 at five f4
to KFI before you also have this e for
square to watch out for I like it
the giri was playing this in his match
as well but maybe I'm mistaken and also
I was just informed the Hikaru has led
seven times after the five in a segment
he's won all seven of those matches
something's gonna have to give today
right we've had Levon Aronian never
trailing after the five minute but hora
wins a lot of five-minute 41-7 and the
tube matches where he's been down in the
five-minute segment better this Carlsen
right the infamous the infamous match
yeah exactly yeah the the world champion
of course celebrated a birthday
yesterday happy birthday Magnus now 28
years of age you know his brother why I
say years of age you know his birthday
present is what to watch this speech
history from chest to watch a chest to
watch that's right
all right it's a blacks position is
exactly that you described a strong
center yeah white has to pawn islands
black is three and what when you talk
about pawn islands sometimes you know
you want to get away yep
transparency
okay it's not Southwest commercial but
oh that was pretty good though Southwest
could be a sponsor of these this is
right up their alley it's meaty well I
think LaVon might start wanting to get
away from this match because yeah this
is this is vintage Shekhar right now
think faster playing better out weak
squares and the light squares and the
kingside are vulnerable black's pieces
by this night being on g7 an awkward
spot it's going to e6 very ugly and that
bishops gonna have to make a decision
you take on e7 black will just take back
with the night obviously we wouldn't
take with the Queen and hang the d5 pawn
right I like it
thanks you too it comes ninety six so we
love the fiend catered nights today you
know I don't you 792 ah
keeping that rook stuck because now that
the rook can't move the knight came over
from g2 oh man it hurts hurts to be this
stuck but before they go that's a nice
move I would take the night the night
instead of the bishop and then what use
your other knights to get in yeah I may
be put h5 as well just sort of make a
little bit of progress in the Kings side
of course I'm in danger of overextending
the King side of the board but that I
take on g4 making White's life a little
bit easier than I really like to because
I feel it should be for Queen g4 and
mine I can now go to e3 yeah this d5
ponds week yeah d1 just play sort of
straightforward chess but I think black
is still better than a line just gives
more winning chances absolutely stinkin
took on g4 okay so this is I always
think when there's some weak light
squares d3 c4 f3
yeah the knight need to gets the e5
square but at the same time I made it
spawned e 5e permanent weakness yeah but
if you could if you could just put this
night here I mean yeah you got access to
everywhere you want to be right f3 and
e3 what did ya blacks nights are not
ideal so Cara's approach maybe got a
little bit overextended because White's
idea is very straight forward the deep
on the target yep Knight f4 I guess to
first stopping easia he wants to stop a
counter play that's a nice move ro
giving us a bit of a scowl they're not
sure where he wants this one to go
and also go ahead you guys go ahead yeah
you go ahead the night on e7 and then if
I were stepping any chose toes yeah both
want to be in the f5 square making
progress the 97 stuck that they both
really want to be on f3 or d3 2 right
that's but this night kind of a key
defender right now and that's difficult
in fact here comes I like this move 94
if you simplify the position eliminate
any chance to black it's counter play on
these squares the steep pawns gonna be a
target right yep that term the big
problem Knight takes d4 here rook takes
d4 you know can't follow it up with
knight c6 or nine at five yep because
the d5 pawn Falls in fact this a5 move
is one you'd like to move back right we
jump with this a lot now hey he wants
the idea of getting eight four and keep
a b2 pawn under his sight so that's why
he did it but I agree with you that the
cards position feels a little bit
superficial artificial being held
together right now and now I think is in
big trouble 90-93
yeah do it oh man I also got some dark
squares over here calling my name
I'm to dinner actually the first thing
that came to my mind
besides d4 is a good make f4 work
oh that would have been nice too is
speaking of the dark square if you would
have loved to open it up and get an
attack but the problem is you're not
yeah you don't want this I would love to
take with my queen and just go for a
checkmate yeah of course things are
hanging good idea keep an eye on that
right f4 94 don't don't forget that hit
car doesn't have a lot of pieces around
his King here yep and so things have
really taken a bad turn for a car in
this game it looked very nice for him
earlier on and I think Bishop takes g4
was the mistake taking the fisherman
yeah I know you called it Bishop taking
that I would have been better
okay so the question is is queen b 5 or
something at a good mood
a queen g4 offering the change ah that's
a strange move to trade off the target
on d5 but the e4 pawn my fall rites of
decency trading one weakness for another
right take stakes and if the rook has to
move instant tactics always a problem
with the short pawned chain that you
once you hit the base poem which is
pretty easy
second pawn that's attached to you I
think he's also looking at rook d6 down
right yep
rook d6 looks tempting let's see what
else can is there another 94 and rook t6
or of course the moves they both look
good
choosing between flavors at this point
Cara's gonna have to sack the exchange
think so I think he might try to do
something 5 times rook takes even know
do you want to say it's overwhelming
alright but it still is feeling very
questionable still not going anywhere
right still weak you could trade and
take a 5 - I mean you take 85 right now
actually yeah and then if Knight takes
we're back to our battery I like it
that's a nice little tactic maybe LaVon
is calculating calculating how he wants
to win a pawn here hey Cara's gonna be
relying on some sort of long-term
counter play against the King side here
he's gonna lose upon osho osho osho oh
patience it's a virtue that we parent
don't have that don't have apparently
here we go
the LaVon doesn't like the movie made
either he's shaking his head yeah why is
he shaking because maybe he just feels
like he is something or had something
better but now just rook I mean we
didn't see any concrete reason why the
pawn couldn't have been gobbled so now
LaVon may have missed his chance rook e1
I know you're protecting this pawn rook
d4 Knight d2
actually rookie for mary 9 takes a 5 is
also possible but I think
as you're not protecting this Yvonne Wow
gobble practical shot there or night of
three yeah both good well maybe nephews
rookie for which is a bitter but at the
end of the line we've also got takes my
check and then rookie for yes ed
Estrella
okay so he just gobbles the pawn I think
it's an interesting practical sack
though by Hikaru yeah it's a clean extra
pawn or white but the problem is that's
a weak pawn right so yeah it's totally
an extra pawn but it's on the e-file its
isolated or to push in a queenless
ending yep that's that's a good a good
thing to do I think when your king is
gonna be potentially weak every time you
push the e pawn right so he's getting
two ladies off so at least he can push
without worrying about his King becoming
more open so isn't enough to win
probably not with best play right I mean
probably black is gonna be able to hold
this time soon the time situation again
a greatly favoring a coral 11 easiest
one he needs to just play quickly by
rookie to rights protector second ranked
and try to regroup your piece yeah and
you wanna you want to find a way to set
up a position he goes for where you can
kind of safely push in these scenarios
yep right without worrying about counter
tactics speaking of which hey Cara not
gonna make that easy kicking the knight
back to d2 and bringing in his own
counter play I may come in to c4 or d3
but look at that nice trying to go into
d4 it's a yeah I like that
make b5 a problem if a 494 would be a
mistake for black can't go 94 here
cousin I take c3 check with check how
can you have three first b5 check
there's also rook to be won you won
every one night before I guess rooks be
194 right rating beat you for b5 but
it's dangerous right right you've got
all kinds of things to worry about here
discoveries and tactics on the king it's
funny we've been talking about white
scheme black king is not so safe either
so sometimes you can get your way active
yeah it's we're giving up a pawn yeah
it's a good point quickly flip the
script but LaVon is only gonna have 20
seconds here again hikaru up on time as
we
near the critical moment which is one of
the one of the worst parts here for
LaVon despite being over Karla miss 94
look he's like shocked right now
nobody Knight takes B 2 and then 1993 or
94 okay but now how do I make this a 4
and Livan doesn't have a lot of time a 4
just do it rook rook before and I see 3
I see 3 quickly get the rook to c2 then
get back to things with the e pawn
yeah after rook B for me there's even
Knight d5 making sure that that rooks
not coming wow that's before well
defended right now by Hikaru though cars
probably better yeah he's no Ruby - and
there's the King yeah why can't you
become in danger looking for a way to
bring the rook to b7 and then the knight
comes to f6 so a Karim not interested in
that gonna try to run up Knight f4 h7s
gonna fall so this is this is gonna be a
race down the finish but here comes yeah
exactly keeps flaking horse coming oh my
gosh g5 threat and g4 but luckily Vaughn
has g4 before Ricardo does it why the
white king just feels so so scary over
here the night comes death regards g5
and friends but Knight if King g3 rising
g3 slides over and now there's threats
of Knight c5 rookie 7 here rookie 7
Laval doesn't have any time though but
he else is about to have to pass pawns
on the Kings side it looks like yeah hey
Carl goes nice takes h2 to avoid that
but the G pawn is definitely yes
actinide Ainge hrus yeah that's what
LaVon doesn't want to happen but we made
him just getting a peaceful result
despite how crazy exciting that was
there that was a lot of back and forth
hard to hard to calculate everything
with no time on the clock but okay right
now Hikaru every time he's under
pressure he seems to just be finding
just enough accurate moves to hold off
Levon yeah and sometimes win the game so
and he keeps going back to this opening
which I'm not particularly fond Eve for
instead of it's nice it's not the
sharpest way from white to play for a
win but when you have a three-game lead
in the match - at this point hard to
criticize it alright it'll get sharper
in this particular game and just you
know reminder everyone we see that
there's been a timer and it's up there
it's left for the five minute plus one
second increment section then there's
sixty minutes of three minute plus one
second increment and finally thirty
minutes of the bullet
one minute plus one second it should be
fun yeah we got a lot of time ahead so
if you're just joining us stick around
for the rest of the day leave your
schedule and and take note of your car
would Michael Morris facial expressions
if nothing else
they've been they'll be quite
entertaining for you if you just got
here
the play has been absolutely phenomenal
but to me this is a beginner David has
been even better as soon as you said he
just leaned in put one finger to the
lips and trying to figure out what yeah
it's going on this position I like
blacks position on yeah again he Carl
hasn't really gotten anything of note
out of the opening here as white right I
mean this has been pretty easy for for
Levon to equalize and head to the
endgame but again I think the biggest
issue is the match strategy already for
Levon if he wanted to have a lead in
blitz he's got to make a move right
because we know what hit car Nakamura
can do and bullet and I like lavon's
position here because the bishop on now
a7 is much stronger than the bishop on
c1 and if it ever goes III you take on
e3 it's a backward pawn yep and the
bishop on f1 is not exactly great piece
either bishop CA will just plant itself
on f5 yeah play simple chess no this is
this is an easy position for black to
play the only open a file here just
equally challenged right now nobody
getting anything I think we'll see
Bishop a5 yep he plays it is is there a
way to rima new ver these pieces to try
to get some play against the king here
94 is coming Brown yeah actually 94 last
move there were some tactics in the air
available photo tries to stop the
tactics on f2 with 94 oh man okay Bishop
Smith looks like wow this is a really
nice move because it makes it Bishop e3
possible now so I think Bishop f5 was an
incorrect move 94 immediately it was
probably wonder if he can spear still go
for things like this let's go bishop
ether right just ignore it Knight takes
f5 would be met by something nasty but
yeah this should be three would be to
move and probably just for ship g6 and
nothing special yeah white it's probably
slightly better in these along because
you're 94 is particularly strong but
it's not yeah look at that move rook a3
I love that super instructive I think
now you have the e3 spirit guarded again
the rook might come to e3 himself you
might come all the way over to g3 so may
I ask you a queen e5 just challenge your
entire setup yeah try to force you to
put the bishop on e3 is too late yes
that's surprising once d5 yeah that's
super weakening to the Queen side yeah I
guess saying if you take on c6 let's
take back with my pawn then shall play
for d5 myself and to d5 here I guess
shooting of the night into the game
I know six looks good but it probably is
stronger force in the d5 so Bishop c5
also an option here yeah okay
d5 probably d5 always look at a six pawn
yeah I mean in every line after you
played that move c6 which is why we kind
of grimaced at it right so man this d4
possible somehow
yeah d4 with the idea of getting a rook
to DA quickly he's so surprised by that
boom but the point LaVon has in mind I
think is to put the bishop on e4 and
then you know maybe try to get a battery
going with the Queen and Bishop with the
dark squares but Korra's not a big fan
of Bishop b8 either that or he smells
something
[Laughter]
rook on a8 it's just it's just not happy
I think that's the biggest issue with
any car instantly played Bishop e6
because of it mission before your move
is a response see a movie night away 92
is met by Queen to e5 rook if the Riva
know a bishop before the problem is now
your bishops in front of the Queen right
and so there's no point in that whole
battery you tried to start right no maid
on h2 if the bishop leads the way okay
Queen d7 unpinning the bishop on f3 I
played Bishop d4 here I like Queen oh
five now here's love attacks
I love attacking we know five
hey now there's maybe a threat of bish
before in the air at times with the d2
night okay so a car trying to avoid that
I think the biggest issue of LaVon could
just put this rook on EA tour something
his position would be fine
well then yeah and then you have to
worry about the a6 pawn right so yeah
yeah so that's the issue is he created
these rated his own prison over there
so his pawn d5 CD v CT v Bishop c4
coming comes c4
I like Bishop c4 a lot how you gonna
protect d5 in fact Bishop c4 Knight f6
it simply take on d5 anyway yeah because
you're all about the back rank some
about the base Oh to check we both saw
that would be nasty it would not be a
fun way to lose all right but nice e5
still is gonna be a simple a simple way
for white should just be better in the
endgame you put the pawn on b4 a6 as a
problem d5 as a problem
White's better right risk free chest
risk free chest my favorite kind of
chest actually dope so between DC I
enjoy the risk Queen d6 doesn't work
here for the record because threatens
mate and the 95 after Queen d6 g3 yep
then 95 runs in a rook e8 check have big
problems they problems
okay well Hikaru again in the driver's
seat here head and then diving in
alright so he's like all right whatever
you're trying to trade the bishop I'm
not interested that was that was
hilarious the point is King takes h2
would have allowed Queen to c7 check but
uh that's kind of like the puppy-dog
look at Korra right there somebody add
some dog ears there's emote material
policies just unbelievable the amount of
face you see yeah so versatile yeah he
should be the next su and ER yeah really
blue steel okay so she loves credit well
not this great position is bad right now
no but to his credit I think he is good
at this kind of setup from black where
he's worse but he's able to hold because
he's a tricky player but again it's
blitz so the fact that he only has a
minute is the I don't even look at the
clock right I mean he's already so down
on time
I would go for swindles I want things
like bishop before so I can mate on h3
but you can't do it cuz look at this if
Queen D for Queen takes d4 Bishop before
now then Bishop b2 comes and you ah
this is the kind of tactics that Liv
finds very quickly right but not quick
enough
oh he's so upset hikaru I don't know
what that's about
laughing I think I was thinking about
Bishop d3 queen of rook e8 and his back
rank is a probably yeah who's rook away
I don't know what he calculated but he's
rolling his eyes have a good time it's
hard for me to focus in the commentary
well this is why this format is so much
fun I mean honestly because this is just
the kind of insight we don't get it over
to you three Queen f3 one the rook on a
802 the Bushmen of oh my gosh he's so
sad out visted yeah so let's show the
tactic queen of three game over or key
mode just hilarious but again like I
just backed what I was saying cuz the
point is like we just don't get to see
these kind of emotions in over the board
chest no it's just so much fun to see
how the players feel even if they're one
is stoic and one of them is we take our
ooh Queen at five here just play Queen
a5 offer the exchange of Queens D pawn
right it's the yep compensation that
you're trying to get but good response
but just gonna be a really kind of easy
position to push for two results here
for a car oh you got you can play for g3
Anna for g3 also though Kings Avenue if
you're too slow my king my grunt into
the center first right so yeah that's a
nice point the King gets to c4 and black
is okay so now if he backs up yeah here
comes love with this idea maybe my car
will play chief for now five to slow
that down oh it was actually a really
good it thought there because of g4 f5
you really just stop the King from
getting there
yep will you lose your f5 pawn but the
more the more you can trade things
better you're drawing chances are yeah
if I'm saying okay for protect you and
then I'm gonna win you're at five pawn
no it's yeah so so love is in trouble
plus he only has three seconds to two
minutes and that's a problem he goes for
this idea oh I don't like this there
should be five over T fives even better
just simple and straight in your card
definitely missed that because now the
prom
after king g2 rook takes a five you
can't take on d4 because rook d5 is a
pin emote is you Wow
I love it love might swindle one right
back here because at this point despite
only having three seconds he's probably
the only one who can win on the board
okay
but again time of the essence obviously
love knows that yep should be a photo
finish only one point nine seconds here
oh why am I so nervous
yeah it's because III here comes d3 and
the King just runs the CC I mean this is
just safer black yeah this is a big
profit Caro can't go King III sit that's
right III if the rook goes to DT of
Bishop g5 can't go kingi for I meant cuz
rookie five check comes and right off
the Brooks only black can win on the
board but Lev does not have the time you
would like d3 he's gonna play oh did he
lose the pawn he did yeah but he supers
King on b5 trying to win the bee for
pawn yeah I probably still gonna have
winning chances here very good winning
chances g6 wants to play h5 keep the
boat but now Bishop e2 is possible
Bishop you - here comes g v g5 first and
then you have g4 but he has no time oh
we didn't see it
g5 and g4 he only has 1.7 seconds what's
going on here is Amaro gonna pre move
swindle him I think it should be winning
for black no I should be a draw just
yeah but the king can get the bishop out
if I have an H Vaughn oh yeah okay not
in time not in time
wow that was wow that was fun that was a
fight with himself because he's like I
had a winning position there yeah what a
[__] yeah he didn't have the time right
but this has been kind of a snot a
common storyline throughout the match
right yeah so you could say yeah just
frustrating you don't have the time to
win that particular game but he's also
been down on time when he's been losing
right so that's what happens when you
play a car Nakamura yeah a new car had
actually a great position all game you
missed that tactic yeah so he should
have been the one winning that game but
she was like quickly things to turn
around especially when you make a
mindless move so all right well we're
back to the Italian structure we've seen
a few times he carro has played the
aggressive g5 approach and then
relocated his knight around I think
we've seen that twice in games whether
lives sacrificed a piece or not yeah
but uh that why i'm steve king each once
and goji five now I dare you oh it
doesn't
let's go G five now I dare you and he
plays it wait what's going on here 95 95
and then f4 comes hey Kauravas oh I see
Knight g5 pawn takes it's a very direct
sequence if I Ponzi's Bishop takes King
g7f for Rick h8 it reminds that vidiq
came from Isle of Man yeah that we loved
so much yeah and then the promise after
pawn takes e5 there's some Knight g4
stuff happening and you might even get
let's just show the mate cuz it's fun
for the kids at home it happens
love it okay we're gonna get it and you
got to really watch out like you said
the video game from Isle of Man was
actually Game one the first game of the
tournament and I think I think I did a
video with him yeah on YouTube you can
check it out very exciting game for
black so what if h3 here is that and
Bishop takes h3 metal even be a
sacrifice oh I don't know who's bad I
mean suddenly black is turning the
tables and again we already just showed
you what happens to be taking five eight
robbed of seven you have this move
though as well in complan the king was
super yeah love is sitting up in his
chair because it's time to think right
yep
a time to think but it's the problem for
him is he spends a lot of time and yes
he may if he wins the game then it's you
know he's validated his use of the clock
sure right but if not then he's just in
time trouble
d4 is an interesting one whoa blocking
the bishop from all these mating ideas a
very principled move - I think just try
to go big in the center how does this
change anything let's say I take on d4
I'm guessing e5 is coming hey I get I
wanted to go so go Knight g4 there so
Indian Eiji
tonight you for I don't know applicated
well we do have some critical info
available to that we're gonna bring you
at the end of this game stay on the edge
of your seat or what hey car Nakamura is
listening to ya behind the scenes
confirmation what do you think it is
yeah we should all be guessing
we saw Ches Bay's you know musical
breakdown chart of what Hikaru listens
to we know he's also listened to the
offspring on previous speeches
championship matches which I know that's
a whole nother issue by itself but but
okay so we'll stay tuned at the end of
the game will reveal what a car is
listening to in today's match probably
the most hype music these days you know
a little bit imagine dragons yeah you
like that Shawn Mendes I think I'm going
to Shawn Mendes I changed my mind I
didn't know yeah he's definitely flee
yes no he's not listen to Mendes got
some Abba ABBA votes he's listening to
Shawn Mendes alright you're so upset
about it I just I'm not another Mendes
guy here sorry yeah alright 'if I've I
like that I don't believe in this then
ig4 still yeah but there's there's no
mate immediately I guess I mean okay
there's still serious problems for sure
here it is
yeah it's why her car saw H 3 he just
jolted back I was like what yeah we've
been night eat no 93 then Bishop takes
Queen okay but h3 this around the world
always right you can't cuz you're not
taking an ing for your pawns pinned yeah
through my queen of g8 or something yeah
you could also play f6 right force the
trade such a risky looking movement but
the point is if it come if it came back
to takes the night takes you would have
your your bishops flying the h3 point
again playing like a car or a Queen's g8
94 is a good move and now you want to go
Knight f6 yeah and you guard f2 and a
lot of positions
it still feels super scary we need to
pack or not with best play this is uh
just play very quick now 19 cheat to
nobody's gonna do Knight G crazy you
know it's funny you lose a queen like
knight eh
kingi to Bishop h3 check I can go King
g3 there but this line would be like the
Queen Stax we've already seen a couple
times yeah or suddenly white might be
winning with with the Queen off the
board
very tricky stuff look at Cara was
calculating it's funny because a car
loves these types of positions oh he
didn't always think him how to sacrifice
how to checkmate this and that so he's
really trying to figure this out here
and Knight f6 annoying threat basics
check is annoying threat so I definitely
see White's counter play despite the
fact that black has to be most of
winning well close the winning might be
strong but just feels like you're near
of a piece right you could take that
bishop on c4 right away if you'd like
yeah I mean maybe that's what he's
calculating just take the money and run
right okay back he does yeah grab the
bishop and then even if check or Knight
f6 you're just trying to get the King to
safety
well how is the King getting the safety
his Queens under attack evil queen f8
you have to have Queen g3 and actually
I'm throwing a quick mating - yep Bishop
h4 check in Queen g5 yeah our Bishop h6
check same same exact mate so after
Knight f6 Queen Queen takes h3 here but
if you are leaning in if you go Bishop
takes h3 right okay if you take my queen
I'd Bishop g4 discovered [__] right
there it is and he does it and if you
take my bishop on h3 now my queen go to
c8 and I've got a new square and a new
target but the King on g7 still feels
the leak yeah
for example Bishop h6 check isn't you
know just to throw a curveball here if
you take a I get to the G no but you've
wrote g6 to block yeah forget about that
G 1 check block it this is crazy crazy
games we've had here I mean has this is
a single game I guess we have had these
boring yes the games where her car was
been white have been less than fantastic
as far as the excitement on the board
but the these games were levies been
white in this Italian have been nuts
from from the first game here they're
definitely treating us to some select
Acula yes alright King h2 like that just
guard it maybe try to get you
Brookes over here to the G file it's
saying if pawn takes c3 over of g1
ignore everything just go from me yeah
even more material sort of a crazy
position that way there's also ideas
where the Queen can come to this
diagonal voucher alright does not look
pleased crazy to believe black is up so
much material but the point is you know
the rook on a8 is out of play at this
point the Knights are pretty but do they
have enough what if I just go pawn takes
e5 is that possible I go rook g1 you
mean takes h3 check whoa I'm trying to
trade off to the counter Queen SAC I go
over KJ check you're still up a piece of
you no no now you're down the exchange
but how many pawns are out yeah that's a
good point but it's still super unclear
because not like blacks Kings out of the
woods yet
cards you see that he's blue on his own
hair whose magneto not magneto mu got to
move got to move got to when you need
him he's so hot right now on sole so hot
right now um somehow of course hey Karl
is so hot right now
well he's not under a minute yeah but
he's up three games in the hand too all
I wants to take off one with check okay
live quickly okay gotta be something
here now okay Bishop h6 you can you can
even just yeah I know you'd play Queen
g8 in 95 but King e6 where's the mate an
f5 check I mean wow this is just it was
right here the King runs and f5 and he
gets hell at Queen f7 and if you're just
joining us we had a game earlier in the
match very similar to this where Lev was
down a ton of material but just moments
away from delivering mate but he was not
only unable to find the maid but
ultimately Hikaru came back and won that
game is black so if it happens again
that would be kind of the backbreaker of
of what if I just go of loves life we're
gonna shove h4 simple and if I case you
have the same idea not working I'm
trying to find the tactic and so it just
feels okay well I was gonna say where'd
you play fi first now you're threatening
check Queen g8
and night here with mate regarding the
e6 square oh yeah 95 90 guard of seven
but Knight d5 Zack in his back in his
Queen again he's gonna sacrifice Evan
and be just fine
poor love how this is exactly like we
saw on that other game hey Carlos axis
Queen and he's winning just amazingly
frustrated there you can see him
slightly shaking his head i candy 7 is
even better because you keep the d4 pawn
protected yeah love is lost here there
must have been something there we back
up before a5 here just feels like white
had everything you could want but we
couldn't find a mate I don't know but it
looks like the king was getting out yeah
somehow be crazy to analyze these games
afterwards and whoever stole them
together our postgame news report will
not have a [__] I have a short list of
exciting games to look at it's just
amazing hey car was just completely
crushing here despite being down a queen
defense that rook swinging over the
Kings side to go to h4 just yep yes
you're still gonna wreckage for you in a
g4 also does the trick King moves 93
more material coming probably takes h3
check game over yeah kingi 190 I don't
want what check and it's just uh wow wow
how impressive has a car not come Orban
today beast he's a beast total monster
yep and 7 to 3 so plus 4 for her
currently that puzzle rush is paying off
huh
seeing tactics even better than we're
used to yep and just walking right into
the face of danger there is just amazing
that he's just clearly saying I'm not
afraid of that mating attack and Lev's
gone for a couple times and failed I
just made a Carver face number 16
because I don't know what's going on in
this opening it's an exchange Spanish
yeah with the Bishop e7 well so we
promised you we'd give you some
information once the game was over and
we have it I doubt he's listening to
this song on repeat because I mean what
human being would ever do that but
jessimae has confirmed it
or listening to who let the dogs out by
Baja men what is this like mm I mean
seriously music selection at times is
really funny but I again I'm gonna
assume it's not on repeat cuz you know
is that how many times can you listen to
that song before you you know have a
tumor grow in your brain
Wow hilarious so thank you for that
information we appreciate it
all right LaVon got some trickiness here
Queen coming to c5 puts a pin on the
knight on e5 so you got to watch out for
cactus also threatening moves like g6
after pawns under attack as well so yeah
actually a carro is sort of scowling not
not super thrilled with uh with his
position here down on time what are you
a rare rare nakamura sighting b3 might
be a solid move saying if Queen takes t2
yeah it goes for it Queen takes e2 you
can even just develop yeah I was gonna
say nice e3 or 92 I know it almost feels
like fake news especially if we find out
it's on repeat
you know just wow alright and just do
you think he's like cheerleader
oh that's another one yeah I don't know
I will ask him afterwards obviously I
cannot believe use this new Nozick's
I was told and I now black and maybe
take me too by the way Robert because
it's it's a skewer on the two nights
right I mean if you take you can't
afford that would be interesting that
might get you in trouble czar c5 there
but if Brooke F 2 c1 is always possible
instead yeah and plus the queen is kind
of in trouble yeah in a lot of positions
so it live has some things to prove here
because he went pawn grabbing the mom is
out playing with the kids here yeah that
Queen is I've gone too far yeah her own
good soaking it over who let the dogs
out why you got to get over
flashing that that's a u.s. championship
ring right there yeah he's getting the
Godfather pose they're flashing the US
chess championship ring he's got a few
of those only 45 seconds remaining here
in the five-minute portion but if you're
just joining us don't go anywhere we
still have more chests left than we then
we've already had happen again this is
the second semi-final match up as you
can see right there
yesterday's first semi finals sent
Wesley so into the championship which
will take place tomorrow at 12 noon
pacific so he he was impressive and
right now Hikaru is impressive against
the bone
yeah and was he so was rooting for Levon
he wasn't really for him because of a
friendship thing there's more so that he
thinks a Cara Nakamura is such a heavy
favorite in this format yeah that he was
rooting for LaVon so he'd have an easier
final matchup in his estimation but
right now Hikaru putting on a clinic
yeah right now I'm not sure I love his
position because Mike is up a pawn yeah
and there's no clear way to trap the
Queen even though we've been seeing some
cheers for it the people wanted but I
don't know the people are gonna get it
but you can't touch your beep make
Castle queenside that oh well that would
be that would be fun so the point is rip
III the Queen goes to a5 and there's
there's no next to move right
wow what a move Bishop e5 stopping white
from IE 5 itself and there is a knight
on c3 being attacked but that Nancy 3
doesn't have any question always come to
b3 and defend it though
now Hikaru has managed to steal the pawn
back and and leave black with these
weaknesses here no I agree it feels a
little shaky for white now that White's
another blacks King is out of the center
you can play rook e8 the e pawn might
come under fire but the D file right
only well the B and the D file is the
open ones right yeah I like this move
because now that the pawn is under extra
pressure it highlights the dysfunction
of this situation we're coming to guard
the knight Knight having to guard the
pawn on a tricky for a white to figure
how to wiggle out of that
yeah and love while also down a minute
on the clock yeah that's that's the
probably the biggest issue in the
position I think black is doing fine
here but okay so Knight takes e4 I guess
it's just take on e5 and just gonna
simplify it out takes takes takes
hey Nora would save sakes takes how
queen c5 here that yeah queen c5 and
Queen d4 are both on my mind oh my god
unbelievable the fact that they have not
figured out how to get a camera on it
karo and over the board tournaments yet
you know I mean this is so clearly the
next thing that needs to happen or chess
yep that's it just only on him yeah only
on him there's two just hey Cara watch
all the time no matter where he okay
rook do you one rook takes c4 yeah the
stick c4 is a free pawn but picaros
gonna get into the seventh ring and
probably white shouldn't lose this
hanging will be down a pawn in the end
but yes the seventh rank the files
probably too active to expect black to
be better but again I think the biggest
issues so far the biggest overarching
storyline in this five-minute portion
has been left being down on the clock so
much in an Hakkar of just being an
absolute frickin monster I love the hora
with horns emote because when he gets
going like this he's just he's a demon
you know I don't like what the car has
been doing okay so that was smart after
if you take on c4 in the check anyone
yeah exactly
check on either one a rookie 3 or roof
d1 and then the rook enters into the 7th
rank you can even see you can see black
getting big look e8 it's still good for
black you're up - oh yeah stops rookie 7
even though it gives up c7 the black
will be of a pawn in this endgame yeah
good point this would be huge for LaVon
just to yeah just to take some momentum
into the next round right have to go
okay he doesn't getting a win here is
black so how do you do it after trades
Andy let's provide some instruction you
play a five and a four so this rook and
guard both pawns ya figure out getting
your King a that seems like a nice setup
you can do that Origen play or just
taking the a pawn
you okay love isn't gonna want to take
the job but now he has an extra tempo
because the sea pawns already guarded so
maybe he thinks he can afford to bring
the rook to f5 to guard I don't like
that
I like Rocky eight much better right you
just you don't want to allow this up
okay I'm wrong he's going for it
it really feels risky because you're
Brooke is gonna be under fire uh I'm not
I'm not a huge fan in a car was going
for this idea but you can't push this
the second Jeep honks I have three four
you can after I've to king of tuturro
but then you have rookie 8c just okay so
that's what he calculate it's a nice
point Joe that if the king of to what I
have rook e8 and White's not in time
okay so now back to the line we talked
about but you don't have a five a four
which is what I wanted that you have to
settle on this end game which probably
should be hole double for white
despite the doubled pawns it's just not
a big enough weakness yeah you know
blacks perspective just gonna go a five
a four just push the pawn pretty far
down the board don't put it to a two
quite yet but oh okay
take it now the G line that pawn yeah
that was surprising but okay cars face
he's like alright that's a little bit
it's not the duck lips more of a puppy
puppy dog yeah you're helping me out by
making that capture the car would like
it
karo hungry sorry I want to say things
that are bouncing around his head what
I'm gonna get from lunch later I'm
asking the same question you know hungry
I want to know yeah okay so that King
looks very advanced of rook a six force
the came back to G Drive King has to
come back if check at some point you
have to push these pawns in the point is
you just there's no progress to be made
white setup the only way white loses
this is by moving things and doing
things if you just sit tight it's a draw
yeah and that's exactly what we have
here so don't allow any little tricks
right h4 v rook a shrunken eight right
that's a karo played g3 himself or the
last tricks you might have us if you
could sack and get your key oh and he
goes for it you could sack and get your
king in
if takes she's six I was thinking there
was a check here and I and I win the H
pawn okay it's not anything there's no
way but if I win the F pawn that would
be irritating I think that was his idea
right it was something like this where
suddenly White's King and the F pawn are
really irritating and just go back one
move here sounds a F for its FG for King
takes H for which looked like a good
movie I made it on h1 King age six th
for that would be checking me soul of
going for one last try here but not
gonna be a now if a car was still
looking very relaxed here is that a
turtleneck under the II had the plan
what he's doing with his style today all
right well we're gonna have a very very
quick break for everybody and so that's
when a car who has been listening to on
his mind apparently somebody let the
dogs out somebody's gonna have to get
the dogs back in if you're Levon Aronian
because right now a car nakamura has
been nothing short of phenomenal and
we're gonna see if Levon can sort of
change the tempo change the rhythm of
this match as we head into the faster
time controls we will be back with three
minute in just a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
oh let the dogs out who let the dogs out
first of all can we acknowledge how
great that Marcus wrote wrote that was
great dude
together we could be a doggy doggy band
well if you're just joining us
grandmaster Nakamura confirmed that he's
been listening to Baha men who let the
dogs out so can't believe that hey we
were pretty sure it was outlawed in in
most the stage but apparently it's still
a thing
what's definitely a thing is the Karaka
Moore's dominance in rapid blitz and
bullets yes and today he's been nothing
short of phenomenal at this point though
there was still a lot of chess left the
three-minute portion what's Levon gonna
do or what does he need to do to turn
things around
weight much faster because especially
this time patrol where there's two
minutes less right then the five minutes
usually play quickly because sometimes
when you play just kind of intuitively
yeah your pony gets down the clock and
they make the mistakes and that car is
of course a brilliant speech chess
player but he's not perfect and we've
seen that in this match he has made some
really critical mistakes that have
allowed Levon not just to equalize bad
positions but actually get advantages so
Levon need to just play much quicker
time second all right well the games are
getting set to begin they we should have
liftoff here in just a moment three
minute chess is underway thanks to all
of you that are with us greatly
appreciate all your support all the
viewers thanks for spending your weekend
with us and we're pretty excited here
for the next segment to begin here we go
Levon Aronian
the comeback starts it cut it starts now
right yep as the Backstreet Boys are
teaching us it's never too late for a
comeback tour thanks Carson Daly thank
you I feel like I'm right back here to
TRL you know I am Carson Daly and I have
a massive tool what I'm have to rein it
in I don't want a radio
I just power so tired we have done the
month of the World Championship done the
SEC everyone's making fun of us I mean
when I get tired you know I get
emotional yeah I'm having to not even
read the chat right now so I'm just
gonna have fun I bitterly barked you
just bark for this show yeah if the
people can't you know be nice they need
to go
baby and go do something else you know
if you're not here to enjoy the chest
and be nice then get out of here
piercing love you Danny so yeah you guys
are loved here whatever all right here
we go let's watch the chest
okay what we got okay that image for the
back to this Italian is just all day
everyday leve trying to prove that he
can get an attack against Ricardo's King
and he just can't
rookie one plates are that 93 is
supported right with the room yeah this
is nice square under control I'm
thinking for black instead of Bishop e6
at some point tempting your king H in
five yeah that's interesting but I like
loves plan because the point here we've
highlighted several times you never want
to take in these structures and open the
F file and give the attack but you put
the knight on f5 and you can just kind
of keep keep the staring contest between
the bishops going in fact it's such a
strong threat that now Ricardo has to
esthar part with that dominant Bishop
right so maybe open nighty 7 here it's
in that way he can keep control over the
f5 square you can take c4 first and then
putting that easy
it's another structure to be familiar
with that this is also not a bad double
pawn trade for white often the D file is
useful over control of the center and
even c5 as a shot in some position so
structural instruction coming here and
the problem is this look at the setup
for white on the kingside official g3
can't move and in h4 can't really move
because we can go to f5 for that ups is
a pawn
so a5 I like that playing on the inside
Queen b3 can come in yeah a rook a3 2 B
3 as well just like a super just thorn
in your side when you have a weakness
like that to watch out for I was gonna
say even if you don't go Queen b3 doubt
aggressively if you bring the rook up
right and I hated it cars move rook to
d8 because I between b3 even have to put
your back on b8 I felt like a wasted
tempo and an important one at that
yeah so now rook well forget for doesn't
work because you can always put that
night back on c6 yeah and it hits both
a5 and guards before but it is an
important thing to just keep in mind
that blacks structure is a little
frustrated over here
when does c5 cut now maybe you go back
to doubling on the default Oh a lot of
c5 I like it a lot yeah because the
Brooks is not doing anything honey also
useful to backup because you can play b4
and slowly prepare c5 if you're into
that that's true actually the slow play
is good play here because sometimes you
got a slow Jamz yeah a5 is protected
I thought you ate some Marvin Gaye's and
Luther Vandross well but you didn't you
know anyway we'll get back to that efore
comes bishop on g3 that's not the
problem right if you could if you could
put the bishop on e3 and then play it
and then protect your night you'd be
happy here but why it's got some
dysfunction to figure out trade Queens
like like Queen d2 at some point to
offer the exchange or do you keep them
up jozek you might if they ain't gonna
take with the pawn and then try to use
the G file baby Wow
okay now Knight a5 comes I guess now you
got a trade but here comes h4 if you're
not careful
h4 Knight f4 yeah level wants to get
hurt a decision yet to get them off the
board and now you're back to threatening
c5 and if the knight moves watch out for
Bishop takes e5 yep and a Bishop h4 just
provoked g5 yeah this feels this feels
better for white now you can get c5 and
he does I like it 95 cars not happy yeah
this is this is not in the best way to
start the three-minute portion I have
feeling the rhythm feel and I think it's
the right get on up it's bobsled time
love runnings left he's trying to get
something going here
oh look you two hitting g6 you can't go
King age 77 check comes in they all
right can't go King f7 either for the
same reason
oh actually you can go King f7 yeah
because you have rookie 7 at the end and
if everything gets trading you try to
take G 6f3 Falls yeah okay six yeah it's
probably doing too much in our head here
but we'll do it anyway yeah so I mean
the king can run up and just show the
line that this might be his best chance
cuz this would be an active trade that's
bad now that's 57 check yeah King h6 is
for it's an f4 you take the 9f for b7 I
don't know why I sung that okay car oh
he's trying to yeah kind of dances some
some problems you can't dance your way
out of oh my god but you can you can
sack your way out of
yeah he's losing you you can dance if
you want to right and leave your world
behind but if you sack in exchange and
you don't get compensation you ain't no
friend of mine
Oh
yeah whoo is he gonna win this that's
the question yeah I don't know if he has
enough actually karo does did find me oh
he missed look alive he shook his head
he took me to is a bad move
wait rookie one check oh there's okay
that's why I don't know DT was covered
from yeah yeah for now he couldn't take
on c7 because rookie one check rook rook
e1 check followed by a fork wait a night
popping him he's six did her cards
missed that Oh b6 super strong oh he
shakes his head yep less than ideal
much less than losing now get your rook
to safety there we go h4 that way if
there's a check you know scream you know
I want to avoid the rook and Knight
mating that right that's how you lose
this game if your wife there's also
meeting that for white now yeah King is
trapped if you get if you get rooks on
the seventh rank somehow not that easy
but with b7 falling and the king and
danger live should get this one yes
should be a game that Aronian binds away
take you home you also have seven yeah
why did he go I think work f7 was
wasting rook f7 gained a temple on the
night and then b7 okay she's going from
checkmate
it likes himself a mated King g5 is
coming check rook d7 also very nice
double threat rook t6 ace and b7 we're
just take there he's threatening Brooke
takes d5 okay now we got to calculate
why does have both sides are getting a
queen oh we might we'll check Ali uh
yeah yeah I don't know what he's doing
but either way oh it's oh my gosh what
is he doing like the dogs out get a
queen I don't know I feel like a dog
right now okay it's okay he's got he's
got rooks on the board if he's not
winning here he's winning for sure we
have a problem but I think Aronian even
with less than ten seconds is gonna take
this one home f1 and start the other
Queen gorgeous g3 we know g3 ago forgot
about all right well the point is we
have liftoff if you are team Aronian
LaVon showing he's not gonna go quietly
into the night you know he
we'll never give up never surrender and
whether he's going full Backstreet Boys
right now with the comeback tour we
don't know yet
yeah and you think they'll have cars
today the open for them I'll go back if
they're looking for a new tool to open
for them yep I didn't like when a car
play this the last time just remind
everybody the format there sixty minutes
in total of this three plus one second
increment portion yep and then we get to
the bullet but okay $50,000 total prize
fund for the speech Chess Championship
not a bad payday for people who are
sitting out there compared these last
few matches to just like they get I mean
I think what did what did Wesley win
yesterday $5,000 $5,200 in three hours
yeah and unfortunately that it wasn't
the biggest payday for Duda because the
match money is split based on win
percentage or at the end you know he
still made decent money you know and
then he lost a loss of chess match for
three hours and had his mom you know
making homemade juice or whatever it
wasn't a bad deal for Duda but you know
look at the structural choice by rody
allowing the bishop to be capturing b6
yeah saying for ya the c4 and a four
pawns a Nygaard a five and now I have
the C file no me me like it I was gonna
call his bluff though but now a carro
stood Ola if he gets the pawn to b3 and
that's what he does 58 I took the e-file
first efile first belongs to black now
this Knight is stuck to guarding the b3
pawn yep
y'all got problems a car stroked his
chin and does not look pleased
especially because lavon's playing very
fast but he right that he went Godfather
right
III hits b3 but he wants to solidify the
Brooks a car like that move at five so
out on the board he's like yeah that's
pretty great ro Hikaru approves you love
when it carro approves it's the deal you
King f2f for work you undestroyed off
though I guess the black King just comes
to e5 very yeah yeah just take it
rookie one King one King f7 king of sick
I mean the plan is very simple not to
mention look at that g3 squared yeah
also did she to pawn is backward I'll be
three pawns backwards so you've got
targets even if this Bishop blacks
avenues currently if you can get the
bishop on a diagonal where it starts to
come into the backdoor here you're gonna
have potential winning chances for black
well I've planted the g3 squares the
King on f6 the Reds go to e5 but also
sneekly oh I like Oh King g5 now just
play it gives you five instantaneously
all right yes sir Knight comes back to e
to the ring I would have been blocked
that may mean that there was no real
winning chances here then there's no h5g
for it's not going age five Oh defending
super well got the King over here to
help deal with this weak pawn which is
gonna free up the night at some point
watch out for that Pony to start getting
frisky if you go don't say bishop beware
I just want to show it's how it's a keen
e5 you go Bishop d3 I'll go here thank
you
five fish of d3 uh-huh Bishop takes a
four very nice and suddenly the king is
overwhelmed according to many pieces
I've pushing for it
you'll doing okay in the clock now down
you know 15 seconds but that's not the
worst thing in the world right not
nearly the type of time pressure we saw
in the five-minute portion when we talk
about that in this format a lot that
sometimes just when the games get get
faster the players just speed up right
and what you need I just saw funny
chatting trying very hard but it's clear
that we're kind of biased for left you'd
like both these flares the fact they're
saying we're biased yeah oh not I don't
think that's true I think most the time
were accused of being biased toward
Nakamura yeah I mean cuz he's kind of so
impressed but everything he does yeah
and and he spends more time on chest
comm and streaming than any other super
Grandmaster so I think I would say the
opposite is usually the case you know
what we are as commentators though I
think you naturally end up finding
yourself emotionally rooting for a
comeback right because you wanted to be
close so if they're reading into the the
emotion of our voice they're probably
right I mean right now what I mind if
LED won a couple games no right right I
mean I'm here for the drama or I don't
know what you're here for you're here
for the the Cheetos and the lack of
judgments cuz no one can see they have
Cheetos hungry they're sitting there
their shirt off they got barbecue stains
on their shirt - oh you know I've gone
full judgment so just I just I'm just
tired I'm at my wit's end
hold it alright 97 I like it yep quit
calling me out I love that guy the
Carson Daly's available I better watch
it it might lose my job
replace one tool for another a wrench
for a daily write game see so he's going
back yeah I know love feels he has the
potential for an advantage here right
see love be stubborn like see spot run
see love be stubborn
the Bishop h4 that was really
interesting when he put in the first
yeah but now it's which of the SAC
didn't work so yeah or at least a second
you know it didn't work in that game it
was super fascinating there's more study
yeah
even love you Dan this line is great for
white if you're if you're not thinking
about rapido I or my maybe feel like I
like whites positions here but Hikaru
also plays this this position so
aggressive eat so quickly look at the
clock right as we have we seen a game
where he hasn't just been fully fully
aggressive over here on the kingside no
he's gone back to that weapon every
single game saying that he likes its
chances here but I liked exactly what
loved it and we're back to the position
again it because if you're just joining
us in the three minute portion Lev won
the first game with the white pieces in
this exact line and IG said it's
definitely an improvement working yeah
in that game Hikaru played a very bad
move here and just lost a critical tempo
and and Lev kind of never looked back so
97 a much better move by a car maybe
he'll go for your idea of f5 Robert
definitely makes sense just cuz it's
your idea no I just you're hitting at
the center trying to go at four and if
you take two and your Knights get free
no way to stop that yeah a little
discovered Chuck well how was your
father right there check-in it in all
right okay so Queen takes b7 work F to
be a traps the Queen that is a lady yeah
this is a much better plan by a Karl
this time around he's holding c5 he gets
the same things he didn't in a game and
he may go for f5 at some point here with
threats of f4 and this Bishop and night
running out of squares kind of dangerous
for LaVon hey Carl like it like it your
idea before it before you know playing
b4 and yeah c5 deals better with that
than what he has if you have the pawn on
b4 here then f5 can always be met by c5
and actually that's a good point
f5 would have been met by c5 there as
well right because of the night hanging
I didn't even realize that and I'm just
gonna pry open the kingside right that's
where his plans with his f3 and her car
doesn't love his position just shook his
head and just in fire great comment
sometimes a field day needs to be modded
to be I need to be muted like oddity
audited that's the same thing commuting
you put me in a timeout yeah no okay so
queen g6 yeah and it actually guards the
night so that now have fives a threat
because when I was highlighting
for is that if you're ever pushing a 5
right White has this nice little shot in
the Knights undefended so so this is
this is a real threat now have five be
on the board soon likely yeah actually
three and GTX f3 as well okay Kings in
h1 because now h4 it's not him he's
going the other direction I think cuz he
sees an opportunity to just play more
positional f3c fours doubled right he's
got nice c5 coming playing h4 himself at
some point yeah and here comes the the
battle over the G file this looks really
bad for white she's h4 here I think he's
just timing it but h4 yeah well now he
stopped it interesting and if Y can go
back for b4 + c5 I just I love the
flexibility of that breakthrough
the car is not happy that he have to
move yeah little little little miffed
little peeved yes a 94 what is the
threat just probably Brooke g6 rook g8
double on the G file and try to go for
something
wow he trades into the ending but he
gets c5 that means d7 is opening up and
I'm not sure why I'm so excited about it
but I do yep you can't take on c7 but
you can watch you can't play here cuz
Queen c1
y'all got problems Wow actually I think
LaVon totally missed that
yeah he's shaking his head oh my gosh
she is just like ro is helping me have a
good time
yeah just makes me laugh and now just
take on d2 v g6 probably as good a play
yeah just a really epic make Scout
miscalculation there I love c5 for the
same reason of rook d7 but just clearly
a tactic that both myself and Levon
missed and now a car probably gonna go
on to win this one and get his first
victory of the three-minute portion the
car was not won yet in the in the second
segment bond is so frustrated with
itself there's a huge oversight the
opposition wasn't great to begin with
yet but yeah miscalculating things like
that is very painful as a chess player
so okay before what
what's the exact idea rook d1 check
looks pretty strong
yeah give a check it's not mate cuz we
got the rook coming back taking on
before can't be bad you take them before
place c6 put your rook on d4 this all
looks pretty working d4 h for a car it's
not gonna give up on the mating net here
he's trying to make a baby over here
looking for mate
in fact Levon doesn't have enough time
to really deal with this kind of
pressure
yeah no good move now rook d2 as
possible yeah actually looks really
dangerous h3 comes and she chooses spot
this is him protect f3 and H with the
Queen so jailbroke f1 but here comes age
three I think
where's rook b2 just so many options
here yes look at that
that's patience right there that's
that's patience okay well actually he's
can let get out of this important its
move oh cars not happy yeah you let him
out
no more mate now Queen e2 he's wiggling
King f1 running watch out for h3 to
become a target if you're not careful if
you check the King too much it'll walk
up to g3 and then and black progress all
of this and a big problem as well
looking at three on two on the Queen
side that's actually the pawns are stuck
on a real advance for black for the time
being because that's why he's offering
the trade of Queen saying the extra pawn
is in the wrong side of the board yeah
he just has to avoid giving up the
b-pawn with Shaq that's why you didn't
put the King on e1 yeah I think it will
probably just see a draw here
that would be huge safe for LaVon yeah
but I think it's where we're headed
because if Queen afore hey Karl could
risk losing right if he if he trades
Queens and loses the H bond that's a
problem only two seconds for left though
so the car was gonna try to swindle his
way to a flag here I keep missing the
fact that he's at no time yeah well I
mean this is the first three minute game
where frankly we've had a reason to talk
about it Lev has played very fast so far
he - he can pre move camp ream of
of the evaluation bars easy pewters
don't understand King opponent King f6
might be as good six can't wait to see
the reaction to that common computers
don't understand go only got one second
that's the issue
oh he's working it oh hey Carl's leg oh
geez GG three go just go can you three
yanqing g4 h 4 wow it's a race okay
they're both in the Queen look at a car
is shaking he wants the e5 pawn at the
end being LaVon yeah I'm busy he gained
a whole bunch of time back on the clock
so not only has Lev in there FP gotten
in a good spot but he's lucky he's now
up to four second f4 cuz all the pre
moves and only white feels like they can
should be able to win this game down the
board Queenie a check okay it should be
a draw but if you check on the wrong
square Hikaru can lose right this is you
gotta be danger danger of a crossfire
check like that and if here then queen
of six or king g5 and again you could be
super careful all of you over quantity
right that one pawn is better than the
two black pawns be sevens hanging f5 is
here comes f5 he could have played at
five because queen chuck actually didn't
win anything I thought he might OKC's no
she's repeating go King g5 again I think
he should go King g5 n f5 but mid he's
worried about his clock situation
because he doesn't leave yeah he's
trying to like just gain time back on
the clock
look at that move baby 7 up move oh oh
but it Cora is doing so well just using
the the time I think Lev was trying to
move the F oh here comes the King the
thing is the Queen can't keep checking
this King will go to d7 to c8 yeah if
you check again on the dark squares
you're gonna have to trach Wiens and
then we have like I said Oh
her car ready really Holmes Francis the
car is really upset right now
take me oh but he's gonna use the time
to his advantage
CC 8 live live oh my god he made a movie
point 3 seconds
if we're gonna camera but Robert keeps
grabbing me every time no what happened
life is fuming he listened he looks he
can't believe what just happened oh my
god what just happened
hikaru traded what was the final
evaluation of that position equal sue
didn't draw the black King would have
gone for the F pawn the White King would
have taken the a pawn
I don't think a lab that he was gonna
take the Queen knew he was something
else yeah Wow and he had only one point
three seconds Wow look at love going to
the caro-kann now oh my gosh what a
heartbreaking moment there yeah
especially cuz he like it's such a
topsy-turvy game with no time remaining
he almost he pulled off a wins saying
how the game is going
that's no I mean also just from a from a
like free moving strategy perspective
you always want to pre move capture
right yeah wonderfully played something
else that just breaks I wanted some lag
on his head I doubt it yeah his
connection looks super solid we can
check ping times but I think he just
didn't pre move taking c7 and didn't
expect it yeah wow what a heartbreaking
loss for love and he almost was
he almost I think was surprised that a
carro traded Queens yeah
wow it was too bad cuz he also had a win
earlier in that game Queen takes p7
check I think you were saying wow the
cars so mad at himself was he doing well
I think he also knew he kind of like he
kind of feels bad about that one yeah I
nobody who likes to win yeah I mean
White's just wait just winning here I've
likely frustrated yeah yeah man tough
moments like this happen and just like
that the highs and lows of blitz and
bullets yes yeah yep
Wow who's that a Carson Daly Oh classic
it's so good you know good win in a
fight meteor Carson Daly I think you
would yeah yeah I appreciate that I need
some more teddy bear yeah it's a me and
oh yeah no I'm just
he just seems like a guy that's like he
just like he's gonna just ask to like
anyway we can resolve this non-violently
while it's already been committed that
we have to fight like in like full
anchorman mode okay so this game take on
c2 the Queen no taint trapped down there
weensy - I guess it doesn't get trapped
but you kind of have to take that pawn
at some point otherwise White's just up
one feet in Queens
hikaru it's not expecting that
that's okay why is yourself upon so karu
is going to press this endgame C to pawn
can't be taken then a night on e 7 you
know is hanging so what do you go you go
tonight f8 and the night may not make
its way back into the game any meaning
and or White's perspective you want to
play C 3 at some moment but C throughs
net always been about a three Rick a to
c1 smart way to start now c4 they played
ah look at that it's actually it's a
huge advantage for white now yeah but
very smart by love to play c5 move to
try to lock this bishop in on the G to
square the issue being that let's go to
f1 route itself so black supporting c4
and even the bishop coming around to the
white square here I think just king of -
yep he plays it for it before I can
highlight him Wow
well super frustrating had us on the
edge of our seat but now love is is down
on time and down on the board but that
just I was such an emotional like roller
coaster that I know I was a she I was
screaming yeah I lost my I lost myself
in the heat of the moment and now I'm
just like okay now I don't say yep you
can also just ping if you if you there's
in fact Levon Aronian has less lag right
now on the server than Hikaru Nakamura
does anybody can type slash ping and
then username on chest calm and you can
see people's connection to the server so
last time we checked lavon's connection
is actually stronger
than Hikaru's so sorry everybody
conspiracy theories over and and excuses
it's just I think it was just a premium
mistake just a bad you know that and
that's what it sounds silly but it's one
of things a car who never messes up
because he plays so much online chess
and we always tell kids like you always
pre move capture because look if and the
analysis board if you pre move capture
the bishop here and if black doesn't
take it it just instant resets it I
think it was just a basic kind of pre
move mistake which is really frustrating
Oh
especially prove with the piece that you
have Queen captures okay the car is
putting a car yeah he's putting on a
show here and right now this is I think
we've wanted definitely you know it's
definitely a frustrating loss because of
the because of the way it happened and
he was longing to could have won but but
it's it's time pressure it's time
scrambles it's what happens in online
games let's see
lack of any chance to survive this g5
can come and just play rook to b6 and
bring your other Brooke in there's six a
four is hanging still but a ticket yet
Bishop a4 Brooke c-47 checks I'm not a
seven check just do many good options
okay Bishop d7 Accardo work in it yep
tough well that's two wins in a row now
for a car Nakamura in the three min of
portion one that was obviously a super
heartbreaker that we were all just
talking about one they're just very very
clean in a game that it now has LaVon
mixing it up further here is white we're
no longer in the Italian structure we've
been seeing Robert our first first
Scotch game right yep here the you could
play series pretty fast here what you
can plant it you can play and you could
drink it yep thank you and I'd you know
maybe sorry another discussion okay now
we have this idea with the Queen on f6
semi open file but white semi open file
the B file is not a much used to the
bish rumba six just showing that down
yep the e control over the e5 school
will be important its and with the e4
square the difference is that
can always move this night and got pawn
after he to kick something at 84 if say
there's knight on c6 is take Bishop b5
here okay I was thinking if that night
was taken then you can just put a piece
in the ETF square like it should be five
hitting c3 liked it you don't want to
put your bishop on either when these
squares okay that's that's a weird
square as well because you really would
like the bishop to be there but it
looked to be freed that's a nice little
maneuver in fact I may get my wish and
her car actually just did like a head
nod of yeah that was yeah that was the
right idea no now I've got I got to
figure something out here was Black
Edition one a5 come back in the game
anyway can trap you wish you could do
this but again the chef's calm bugs
don't allow it there's black will play
for c5 is that an idea just to get this
Bishop some life I love it but I also
feel like maybe I should call the bluff
Bishop III see if there's only to play a
stack right I expect LaVon to play
either Bishop 8 through your Bishop III
but okay this is a little more solid
protected keeps an eye over here Oh a
different move he's gonna meet g6 and
Knight g4 now he's got the bishop coming
back here oh maybe he wants the Bishop
c5 it's a strange position for the
bishop all the way cuz Bishop g6 doesn't
work now bishop g6 Queen g6 95 yeah
honey fun
yep yeah I was gonna say in a series
Falling oh that - thanks black's pieces
feel off yep
95 is a possibility here my 95 Knights
pinned on g6 oh yeah it's a material but
maybe he goes for it hey car was happy
to give up you might have to [__] go and
he's going for it kind of gives a little
shoulder shrug like well all right let's
see it right I like that move before
take it up simplifying fixing your
structure and opening up coordination
mean f3 doesn't that in a pot cuz Queen
f3 and 30g for an opponent c6 yep
Everage III I understand it you don't
have your book shut out with d3 coming
but still coming
indeed you bring the rook over problem
is if you get c5 I mean who's better
when you have to pass pawns going right
I've got to be super careful
thank you cars ain't fine here
probably pawns are so strong Bishop d6
offers a trade a queen oh I don't want
to trade Queen still I don't want to you
can also play g6g six
I'm just not a little less fond of it
because it does make my field I can't
feel a little vulnerable though you're
right that still a possibility another
way to offer the Queen trade and not
only that you look how dangerous the D
pawn suddenly is right right Darrell's
back in town so what do you do here if
you take on a 525 rookie five at pawns
going d3 next in h4 feels like it's been
a little bit of that kind of day here
for LaVon like he he outplayed Hikaru's
white in this game had pressure force in
exchange sac and her car was like
alright that actually healthy three
rookie three just missed it your score
oh so now what Queen c4 she I can take
c6 yep probably enough to win the game
Hikaru shakes his head he's gonna have
to make like t-swift and shake this one
off he's going down business it's a good
business to be in the back ranked
business right now and just rook e8 over
a huge bounce back here for Aronian yep
not get a lot of yourself you're only
tilt t2 is the idea maybe why not just
okay but I thought you were taking on G
and playing rookie I would check nobody
take with the Queen on G so the ah okay
yeah uh yet but now this feels a little
like we're moving backward here I just
take a five yeah Hikaru a little
skeptical of it - rookie five goes for
the a pawn the old fashioned way
although then Queen before might come in
you can also play Brooke c1 and try to
threaten Brooke take C to any mode yeah
I mean black is trying like I said
rookie five Queen before and just trying
to get some counter play right to push
this deep on that pawn pushes then can't
stop I'm going to d1
see Brooksie for I like that now he's
threatening Brooke take c2
okay so what took Queen b6 hey I'll just
bring the other Brooke up yeah there it
is rookie four so he's just keeping B
for defended f2 s protected as well now
he can a rook F for is the possibility a
black still has counter play here rook
e8 is possible just to keep them all
right so where's the knockout punch
that's the real question how can Lev
make the necessary progress to end the
game this rooks are great they need to
get in the seventh rank right if the
rooks on F 7 e7 or something like that
you're threatening mating ideas g3
necessary was pinned and just a few
moves away from Brooke d7 wreck f7 I
mean concept just to get some chow
yeah King on h7 you know life is
thinking at some point yeah I should
take on d3 I know it's just it's gone so
backwards from where it was in the
seventh ranked pin everything down
vision one C two can't do anything yeah
here we go car defending g7 all is might
but you're right though I think at some
point you may see this transition
especially if you can take advantage of
the rook being pinned to the king right
okay big car try for rook takes h4 with
Czech sirs we need to oh you miss Bishop
b4 checks up all the Sunday carro is on
the attack despite being down the
exchange but g7 is hanging Oh F 3 can he
get away with that I need to check
mazing hey Cara's face was just really
to King age 3 and the King runs up what
a fine by Lev yep and if Reza what an
amazing move right there yeah obviously
ridiculous seriously yeah that's like
making a walk on the wild side you're
trying to be Lou Reed right now no I've
just I mean anybody who laughs face a
danger gets a simple reference in my
book oh man
we know it's go through Magnus my full
Magnus old Magnus almost instead of the
same line with a knight c3 crazy stuff
yeah yeah just trade it off Queens and
okay okay well this is a structured
dinner for those of you who followed the
World Chess Championship or our coverage
of that event for this entire month you
know that we saw this happened in Game
five games Game six no Game six the one
that you know the infamous game that
ended where Fabiana unable to find a
forced mate in 36 right yeah he's such a
pot sir
can't find a 436 dad no but seriously it
was a game that Fabiana actually played
brilliantly and outplayed the world
champion but just kind of got super
unlucky and I wasn't able to get the win
so he Ricardo trying to go full magnus
look at live guy night g8 bring in the
night around 87 he'll probably kick the
bishop
first here no he should have yeah maybe
he should have I don't know that that
transition it's not the normal case
where the bishop air is just so good for
black but hey his heart has a different
idea take on a five he's gonna give a
dis bishop here okay yeah so right that
he's not worried about giving black the
bishop here but decides he'd rather keep
the dark square one on the board that's
very smart right yes
nice night bishop means that the light
square bishop can't kick a night off to
the dark squares yep but if you keep
both of your bishops then you can always
try to trade your ducks or Bishop for
that night so very good abscission my
left keep his fish from the boots now I
but if this is a position that doesn't
have a ton of excitement when you first
look at it but they can play this one
for a while
well I can try to slowly push for for a
grind here I like this maneuver make
sure b2 knows who's boss h5 is coming as
well yeah what we saw but wait a second
watch out for Knight takes d5 yeah was a
lot of things wonder if he played rook
b6 a little too quickly there cuz rook
e8 say if you moved this Bishop to show
the analysis there was a shot like this
hitting the rook and all the sudden
White's just winning on the spot each
for the best move another discovery ID
perhaps not yeah that's what I was just
showing in like no seven but maybe you
still could have done it here it's not
as good right b2 hangs yeah because
you're not mating black and and so but
that's probably why it didn't work but
but yeah interesting tactics on the
board now all right so he's provoking g5
just leads me to believe that just a
weakening g5 will come at some point r
b5 now is yeah and and b5 we talked
about this a lot during the World
Championship Robert have winning even if
you have equal structures you can still
make progress with moves like this
because you create this anytime you
don't have a pawn with another pawn in
front of it that's a pretender it's a
pawn that's almost a passed pawn and you
can still create dynamic chances there
Sophie ooh
nice maneuver to get the rook out trying
to fix the weaknesses over here on the
Queen side so do you want to trade a
pair of rooks like with rook e8
or black I think you do at Bishop c2 is
an idea to keep in mind as well
I would you know rookie ages offer yeah
exchange saying your pond would be three
is not really that comfortable
the biggest advantage again we see here
is is hikaru up on the clock
overall live has played much faster in
the three-minute portion which has been
a big reason I think why he's doing
better
ooh five but here and now five yeah well
he just puts his head in his hand I
think love just frustrated that he he
missed this idea of the bishop coming to
the back door coming to g7 now okay so
what's the deal on the Queen side now b6
not sure I love that move could have won
f5 but he don't want to block in his own
Bishop that's clear at the point so
Bishop g7 is king he seven doesn't wrap
it you go picture page six nice
technique here by Hikaru honestly I
played King g8 in the tempo I don't
think my King has done the best square
in d7 and I kicked the bishop way
because your bishop can't take G to have
an amber so protect beef right yeah good
move good point now take on oh you don't
want to take are your Pony fives
protected maybe maybe move the bishop
off g6 so you don't see you can fix this
issue it made me like Bishop C to ship C
to ship D three goes to C 2 and and the
rook has to be careful cuz OC 4 is a
move here a 4400 C 4
I saw it coming just ouch and the point
is after takes takes the pawn is
overworked by the fork threat on d6
Knights your Bishop d3 why should be 3
was maybe a little more accurate but the
king was coming to e3 anyway I was just
about to highlight that your move is
more accurate cuz I liked it you had the
threat of a 4 but hey Carter found a
concrete fret but this okay that's a
nice little nice little way to work a 7
H bond Ferguson Bishop b6
yeah the d4 pawns weak be threes with
Fred Zack here by Levon and I like that
he came up with it relatively quickly
because after missing c4 you could have
really gone in the think tank but he
can't afford to do that with only 30
seconds yeah okay if b3 Brooke b2
and the pawns gonna fall right so now
repeat III comes very quickly rook V 2
is coming next
also this night can relocate once the
rug comes to be - he's trying to get the
- passed pawns connect yeah this would
be fun I don't even sure that works out
yeah cuz if takes takes d5 are the pawns
just too slow
it looks slow but may just work a 7 here
ya go go go through the back put the
brook behind the pawn a g7 threatened
rook b7
yep got to be pretty straightforward for
white hair LaVon was making progress
earlier and then just overlooking c4
yeah one shot this move right here not
44 yo-yo mom's sphaghetti pawns are
blockaded which means that okay he's
gonna play this move oh I thought he was
gonna play f4 and g3 but but now Bishop
gets to e1 yeah the thing is oh wait no
rookie chick just went so yeah that
would go Bishop you wanna know sperm my
king for hey don't play rook takes cuz
then Bishop e1 would be good but LaVon
gotta give him credit he's created some
some real drawing chances here ah
that was a nice move bringing that pawn
and now that right Brooke right there
and actually you lose your h1 to h2 King
you for fiber f4 and it's over this
donkey would say that is a nice Boulder
well Caro has seems to have rebounded
here and finding his form a little bit
in the three minute portion
even though Lev release what what blind
is this I have no idea it's coming fast
though you know this might be a game
between that what's the Ephron's Erick
sports off organizer okay yeah I think
he played like Vichy well like like in
something like yeah they're like some
fun game and this brings a bit familiar
maybe I'm mistaking the
but white seems to have some kind of
pressure if you get the Bishop on f6
that black King isn't getting castled
but the fact that a car is playing is so
quickly yeah means that he and that
that's vintage number seven that's the
difference between when you look over
the shoulder to try to remember theory
okay now he's gone fool that's number
eleven no no no number seven number
seven sorry sometimes he can have me on
the edge of my semen as the world's
leader in the car knuckle more facial
expressions I even I make mistakes you
know nobody's perfect number twelve is
closely related it's Queen c2 coming
here
oh then there's ninety seven yeah you're
just in time there's ninety seven idea
maybe Knight g5 that possible so if
Knight g5 ninety-seven I go Knight takes
H seven trying to get know
okay stop in 97 yeah makes sense but
I've 97 97 King takes t7 what comes to
eat really fast whites underdeveloped in
the queenside
yeah but this Parliament g7 that's such
a new this is a nice way to just change
the the tempo or the the change the
nature of the game with the king being
on ei Brooks being disconnected all of a
sudden everything about blacks position
starts working together very resourceful
a car Nakamura okay we should d8 I think
I think if white can just let everything
get simplified but somehow hold on to
the darks for control of the g7 pawn
this nights gonna come from b3 to c5 d4
maybe from f3 to e5 way maybe night c4
here no it doesn't work oh that would
have been nice the point is why point
why it doesn't work is because black has
bishop d5 in the empty one what do you
one would threaten it I like it I like
that I like the way you know he just
backs up for some reason that's also not
a bad idea because now if the bishop
comes back to b6 you can play Knight to
b3 I'm just kind of you know force the
trade keep control over the dark squares
right and whites currently have a pawn
yeah White's up a pawn so even if you
gain that pawn if you have structural
problems in a king in the center it's
not gonna be fun yep let's see 93 Bishop
h6 so okay what's the nice e5 check l7
Queen g3 oh wow what I think nice move
is if you trade opening up the H file
you're never losing a piece yeah she
takes everything you go here first any
mode thanks tactics there it is Queens
you found it but okay I was gonna say
Kim black played fish before and hey
Karl plays it before I can highlight
some Queen h4 Queen is working her way
and now get the King out of Dodge
he does so the h7 pawn not quite yeah
not quite falling you got the x-ray the
efficient ship is defending the rook
from behind oh I like this move this is
the right transition because white
doesn't need to hold on to the g7
I think well yeah you're gonna take h7
aren't you I think so I would look at
war this should be for now f6 is falling
okay so take if you take on I ate the
cheap pawn is on g7 and do I need to say
that again what if you take on g8 g for
nice all in where's my emo when I need
it I think you could find it
I feel you've away I feel like I always
have a way I wish twitch had a way where
you could just press a button and it
like does like the last emote you did
does it instantly
oh just dream Jack does that oh we got
to get our stream deck rockin I got
myself a stream deck I'm all I'm all
into the twitch cool kids now got myself
a stream bed but I haven't used it yet
cuz we've been all busy with a small
event from London all right but this has
been a great game by Lev if he wins this
one hey you don't blunder H to mate and
you should still go on just go Queen h5
h6 x6 now you're threatening to trade
Queens nice if you need are just go g5
push your pawns through ok so you can 86
check I was gonna say you can just play
this cuz if the bishop takes it right if
actually is just very good there should
be six pony six Queenie six Queen h7 oh
that I just got myself made ignore me
okay but now the Queen comes step four
and it just feels like I'm a matter of
moments before but but now Hikaru is
threatening to take and get you seven so
Lev has to put this one away a car was
not gonna beat yourself I've here it's
not like blacks King is very safe oh
yeah I like this move no okay Queen
takes before but a lot of Queen takes up
six but I think you Caro can just put
the Queen back on this diagonal and keep
h2 in sight
yeah 26-minute queen h8 and just it oh
he goes for it
queen bee - Wow he's threatening Ruchi
to check now as well maybe on no time
for love we need seven
he said he's Austin throat of this game
should still be doing okay
OD for saying what check and she said oh
my gosh Uehara once again over gift - is
king h1 Queenie for check oh no such a
resourceful defender just felt like that
position was just moments away he met
him at Queenie forecheck there and I'm
queen for a chick fight I've been
winning nice move there keeping the
Queen cut out yeah every key for King f3
h3 play yep yeah plate quickly we need
six very nice
so even material somehow after all yeah
and an but lèvres king is white AFET
what's he doing six nobody wants the two
pawns yeah the problem again though is
the time Oh Queen a seven check my cards
behind a four he's gonna force the King
to let the Queen come in with check nice
maneuver oh but look at that if he takes
suddenly black as a pawn that's much
further so maybe I can't go d3 b c6 is
hanging nobody at King a3 anything safe
there
oh my god but LaVon has no time Ricky -
and he falls what in the world playing
with her Coronel more in these positions
it's just not fair fun it's not fair
it's not fun it's not safe
it's hardly family friend friendly I
mean it's violent what he just did is
frowned upon and I think in some areas
of Florida
yeah let's remind everybody just about
to go to our daily question in a real
way and our producer behind the scenes
shout-out to Oren if you haven't given
him your love lately he deserves that
doing so much awesome stuff to help just
comms events and our shows be the best
they can be so who is responsible for
letting the duck
you were so like seriously I was just
about to do the daily question which we
should get the day the question back
because I saw some discussion earlier
some rare productive conversation coming
out of the chest comm TV chat them
suggesting and asking which young star
might become world champion they were
talking about Duda talking about
Ragna nanda prague nanda nah you know
they're talking about some people who
may have a chance to vie for the world
title but that goes well with our daily
question which is who should we invite
to next year's features championship
with the young Duda kind of taking the
event by storm so it's uh it's nice it's
nice when discussion as is is productive
and and healthy you know and kind so
well it's not kindness acharya Nakamura
Nakamura is not kind today he's doubled
Levon Aronian score 12 to 6 and it
looked like LaVon was gonna have that
last game he's saying that numerous
times but Hikaru is too fast too strong
and just plays with that energy that's
necessary I just saw AG too weak too
slow in the chit and the twitch chat and
I don't think LaVon is too weak too slow
but I think whenever you play a car
Nakamura a lot of people feel that way
because he's good and he's fast and he
brings it so let's see here got some
control of the dark squares on the Kings
side but black stills a dark surfer
Bishop black has control the only open
file that's meaningful right now the a
file ok the white rook ensuing ink one
at any moment
though after quitting d4 plantings rule
is I would just go Knight c7
ah but you can't really put your name
east six so he's he's annoying because
if upon f7 becomes overloaded very quick
so yeah trying to figure this out 96
Bishop f6 comes 96 Bishop 6 and then you
have threats like Bishop takes g6 Knight
is undefended
yeah a car was sitting with the bishop
here but I think lavon's position is
completely fine there's just no no real
targets for either side I mean from a
match strategy point of view isn't an
ideal kind of game for love right just
because at this point this end game
might take another five minutes off the
clock
I mean honestly right right they could
just keep playing this forever and
before you know it you're running out of
time to stage your comeback of course
the car not come or it probably gonna
make any comeback difficult in the
bullet portion anyway because you didn't
get the memo I'm gonna get that TPS
letter on my desk he's a little by
morning whoa not sure his s4 is not
ideal
now now white could get in trouble over
extending these pawns and making targets
yeah I think he wants to go g4 g5 check
and an f5 that fight first yep
try believing it there's Knight c4 to
start with give me some problems for
white because if you lose your life
score Bishop yep and your problems the a
two point I assume this to pawn via the
a2 square yep and in 94 Oh worse the
loss of light square Bishop a4
overlooked by a car for sure yeah and it
gives a small grimace but you know what
he's not overlooking is the time
situation I have a minute on the clock
Knight c4 so again as I was highlighting
before
now that forces the trade and so Roberts
idea of the c2 pond being a problem
maybe took the deep on yeah I liked yet
we didn't but that might have been
interesting to open up an avenue for the
king he still got king of five kingi for
okay two years yeah
this is probably resigned with rook C
ones at my Bishop a3 take on c2 it
should be one now King
king of 5ya Sakina five yeah I like it
rook b6 you know I was gonna I was with
you give up the c6 pawn but no love
trying to have his cake and eat it too
trying to hold down the Queen side here
comes a threat of Bishop g3 though
Nakara playing very fast keeping
pressure on the seventh ranked King b8
would kick the rook out of here into
that now he wants maybe he'll pull it
does he think he's winning if the rooks
come off the board because of the C pawn
yep right cuz the same people miss show
the king can come all the way up and
then you put your Bishop on a square
like a five well the air is you just
you're there yeah so many of them I can
get frisky with them sometimes you look
at that Jay clones we don't know who you
are but we love you thanks for all the
support all of our subs all of our mods
everybody who's with us we appreciate
you we love you thank you he loves ya he
comes back to bees going for that idea
seven rook moves and ambition ah yeah
you can't move
so the Ricardos playing pesky chess and
LaVon having to take time to come up
come up with the right plan laugh should
be very fresh
yeah and love needs this game he needs
to start to work his way back into
things here done her 30 seconds on the
clock so right now he's been saying way
too much time know Cora's mind I love
you know I love you okay over here
I'm Vasu point it's not your fault Good
Will Hunting okay even when LaVon gets
these really promising positions right
car was so resourceful yep can't quite
convert on him
if LaVon just shocks on became a decent
bullet all of a sudden just right just
choices rolls through Nakamura in his
home territory yep could be yeah we've
seen this mission before one game where
are played have six know where you put
Bishop f5 but I kanji six
yep see similar position is another game
we'd like to move on to a four okay
three yeah that was nice lift
hey what a car is gonna change up here
cuz he doesn't need to go bish me if I
like he he's trying to figure it out
because bond going back to it boy did 95
yeah so this was the position we had but
the bishop yes was on a five and the
night chose a route via e7 so the car
we're taking a different plan here but
but LaVon still into his Bishop h5 idea
I like to e5 square I mean I will say
that but I but there might be a
sacrifice possum yeah and we already saw
her car sack in exchange in this and
this position this type of game
the last time they had it I always loved
that Bishop a3
you gotta love it it just feels good to
the to the skin like like like our
shirts like our polos let's get on your
skin right see how long I could be salad
before I love zombies comma dick or a
finding time to play from his police
surveillance van like episode of Law &
Order and he's about to open the doors
and there's ice-t standing there saying
let's go get these guys what's going on
here some nice c4 and I'd be three stuff
coming yeah your future for Jong he
brought the heat of the island man
definitely trait great suggestion she
amazing more than deserves a shot tank
tank was right on our short list to get
an invite into the SEC qualifier so I
don't know that he I mean he said he's
an online legend I don't know that he's
a world top junior as much as online
fans don't really yeah maybe thinker
compared the same level of strength of a
guy like Zhang and there's nothing
against Andrew he's a monster and much
better than me but yeah but Zhang's not
a bad suggest and John's played in the
SEC before from qualified actually in
2017 so deaths
yeah Geoffrey because where's Geoffrey
rank now in terms of the world's top
juniors he's up there five top five
right yeah so Zhang Zhang's a good
choice you know but I think we already
had such a great suggestion if you
missed our daily question earlier
someone responded why not hold a
tournament that's an invitational just
for all the world's top juniors and
figure out who wants to be there by
letting them play each other right and I
like it oh we have no one mentioned Sam
7 c m7 right yeah oh it's a wonder Liang
I mean there's so many good choices as
American players mention artemiev we saw
Ali Riza Joe was mentioned from Iran of
course are a number of Indian player
with Neos aren Yogananda yeah faroush is
a good choice because well so is his
compatriot who won the World Junior yeah
um yep
it'll be fun I think that tournaments
happening so if they're watching it's
happening yep alright what's happening
here bill Lumbergh what's happening also
40 seconds and counting down right now
for this time segment here right with a
three minute and one second so right now
with the black pieces
it looks like Kazakh are so used to
saying yeah I wanna Carlson real
champions should have been living there
but I think black is a little bit worse
he and the reason why is is pawn on if
you can to send me open beef up those
those two things and he agreed ah a
little bit King now king Safety's gonna
come to quote live rook b1 hey not quite
I'm here
laughs is probably thing about g4 to
break open kingside yep I like this idea
a lot
b5 is a good move by a carro kind of
fixing the weakness there on b7 yeah now
you've got pressure got c3 under fire
right so t3 though it's it's well
defended for now efore is a big target
it work e6 so that you can play b4 for
black and trying to trade off the
Queen's yeah no black has uh mike has
worked his way out of it the position we
saw earlier now the bishop coming to c7
you might have a battery watch out for
it rook comes day one me all the way
this is one all the way mate yes when
white nice he was getting the tech put
the rook on a six or a set well a six
don't back isn't be work that shocked me
okay if you had one extra move you could
play rook a six that are very good but
yeah an hour okay 6/10 ring d5 now d5
takes rook g6 check the g5 at the end
now a lot of pawns are hanging from
black love it six king f7 rook g5 and
when C 3 and push that beef on take d5 I
think so you give all yeah it's Martin
to say ooh he wants to hold d5 that's
better maybe but now Brooke can come to
be six if he wants or he's just gonna
Peter it out we may we may be getting
ourselves into the bullet portion with a
peaceful result looks like indeed that's
what's happened Wow and flexing he was
flexing I think was stretching jacket
it's I don't just what it is
I keep to say like what is it is it
corduroy is it you know how does it feel
on his skin I don't know these are
questions for her car Nakamura so we are
certainly gonna get into after the show
the important stuff but we're gonna take
a very quick break as we get the players
set let them take a breath before we
move into the fastest portion of the
speech Chess Championship format don't
go anywhere cuz bullet chess is right
ahead and it should be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are back here 2018 semi-finals of
the 2018 espy Chess Championship
alongside me the one the only
Robert Hess get at him on Twitter
sometimes mirror effects are weird like
I could never be a weather guy right
what's about to happen is the storm of
acara Nakamura is moving in from the
north and we're headed into the bullet
portion with Levon Aronian and Hikaru
both ready and let's get set and let's
do this thing
right here right now that was extremely
well played yeah yeah little weather
forecasting there really yeah I just
thought that you were going nowhere with
it and all of a sudden you turned into a
positive little skit you know all right
here we go this is gonna be exciting no
matter what has happened today this is
our the last chance to see what can
happen between Hakkar Nakamura Levon
Aronian before we move on to the finals
which is tomorrow so if you're marking
your schedule or planning your Sunday
you should plan it around 12 noon
pacific time to tune in and watch the
speech s championship it will be the
last match of the year right now Wesley
so is simply sitting there waiting
patiently waiting for a chess player to
explode on and that's what's gonna
happen
yep tomorrow right now with the black
pieces
LaVon opted for the caro-kann yep and
Hakkar okay slightly better with the
white pieces nine and c5 as advanced
couldn't take them b2 there cuz they
were to open up the B file with the rook
one ideas and okay this punt a4 as well
could become a potential target right if
I can just there Knight b6 already
threatened it means e2 is the response
and it's a very solid setup for both
sides c3 d4 b2 that pollen chain is
great yup same by the same token the d5
scores ultra well defended for black and
so it's hard to make clear progress
watch out for Knight takes c6 sacrifice
yeah I was gonna say could he do it but
he didn't quickly backs up that rook
takes c6 also you know you keep your
eyes oh he's tempting oh he's tempting I
wanted it so bad but why he's just
better because the pawns e6 is actually
a target whereas the poem b2 in the base
of the chain is not easy to get to okay
nice move reacting to c5 with d5
whoa okay light-square control yes fine
is and again if you just take a second
to consider and appreciate that Hikaru
is still up on time he has more time now
than what he started with and that's not
a rare thing that happens when he plays
bullet yeah but the one second increment
he just adds time it's his clock and
it's ridiculously impressive frankly
since looking LaVon he's on 42nd yup now
already used 40 seconds to carve a plank
so fast and up on the clock now there's
F was gonna say there's f4 but he plays
it faster than I can highlight it and
that's another thing that happens often
in c5 check King you can run c4 is a
target so it's not
I'm Maddox you've rook d4 and e4 yeah
he's gonna do it anyway take on b5 you'd
like to just start rushing and maybe you
can push d6 yeah why wait
but now the 8th longer black is coming
before the chef is Bishop has to guard
d7 so that the rook can come back but
here okay if 91 now you threaten a 2 and
C 3 at the same time rook e8 rook e8 a
to take 98 Queen I don't have enough
checks although I do have Queen check in
the night check but the King's gonna
hide on h4 the car was calculating this
whole thing right now I'm telling you
look at his eyes yep he's going for it
take we're gonna see exactly that you
know you take get a queen in his / EI
rook e8 even rookie eight or a eight I
think they both work cuz the king can
hide I don't think he wants to go to h4
that seems very risky but I think you
might get mated if you're black anyway
he's taking a moment okay he's kind of
bailing out now to get the Queen with
Chuck rather than going for the ones we
wanted but you will probably meet this
with Bishop she 282nd know okay I didn't
actually like Bishop you said now I
liked you might have to idea this is a
weird right III comes into g4 suddenly
Wow whoa the Queen comes he just walks
right in the discovere check like it's
nothing I love it 26 KZ the queen and
night are super danger takes new takes
h5 was on the board the pawn was pinned
on g6 ok a car will probably try to
settle this out with a draw no I was
winning he's winning now cuz g6 falls
yep with Chad oh and he plays Queenie a
check oh man and he's feeling it he's
feeling it a Caro is feeling it he's
bouncing bouncing short if he's again if
who let the dogs out is still on repeat
we have a we're gonna have a big talk
with the car after the show but she's
just joining us one of the songs the car
was listening today was Baja men who let
the dogs out do Berlin and bullet take
that for what you will yeah Berlin and
bullet okay so we got some mainline
Berlin action yelling on the bullet
portion of bish 26 even if you were able
to capture it F takes c6 that kind of
structural transition is not Pro knows
these positions so well yeah - I mean
not that Levon doesn't but this is like
so easy for him to play with with the
black pieces I mean you don't believe me
look at the clothes Grisha crocheting
something like I think it's maybe he
took any seven first
it's amazing how deep the Berlin Theory
has gotten I mean we saw hey Carlos
match with Maxine bushy look Rob right
last year's SEC yeah I mean we had so
many Berlin's and these guys were we're
going into the 30s with theory okay
Brooke period a five is it possibly be
than B five as a response I love to
break open the B file you just not no
time now a five if you what's his idea
here was cancled I don't try to figure
it out but it moved me too quickly and
too well for backup the bishop so you
don't have to deal with Knight g6 with
tempo possibly oh no he does and he gets
the tempo but now you got to worry about
the e pawn and some lines takes there's
nothing to do about taking with the pawn
now white just has the two-on-one Oh f5
s a nice move 97 get that pawn coming
into c4 and White's King being a little
bit exposed could be somewhat of an
issue so here comes the H a quickly
honey shade I love that and if you Kings
right - there might be some pins with
room oh that's a good point and now all
the sudden the King has overworked LaVon
having to come up with the right
maneuver now this is Simone where you
could blunder easily and you only have
20 seconds I like that move aggressive I
would take it a B for C for Bishop III
and just try to push my d4 pawn to d4
okay put it first yeah now there's no no
more devastating checks really okay -
coming yeah well I'm the first for a win
here but not enough rook d3 brocade 750
for second repetition Nietzsche 53 King
got five mate hey Cara will be crazy
King of Fighters for I've checked oh
nothing
Wow Ronnie car seems so confused I don't
know I think he maybe he pressed the
draw button cuz he thought they had
repeated three times or something and
they hadn't I don't know I saw the same
little quick like you
he may go Queenie to mouseland oh my
gosh oh my gosh well this is lavon's
game to get yeah if you're gonna get any
game yeah boys when your parents King is
on e - people like that the bong cloud
lives it this is not the bong club but
yes it's uh potentially similar it's
funny because White's not doing so badly
here yeah
Castle by hand it's a completely normal
position just maybe down like to Tempe
yep the chat going nuts they love that
maybe he carved it on purpose for the
20,000 of you with us
who knows I doubt it so I didn't go
Bishop c4 okay okay the night comes in
to h4 g6
I mean f7 is a possibility here just
defending everything yep right and
you've you've also got the controller
here the light squares spy on game
should still give led a decent game here
I know he didn't punish King e2 in the
way you would think but Mike still has
some potential for an attack but look at
the clock I mean is he serious hikaru
especially to find King to e2 so early
right he had to take no time to work his
way out of it I have no idea how to
value either so it's getting crazy
yep so Queens completely serial right
now super cereal super cereal 7 pawn is
hanging but perhaps it's not valuable
things start going over I would just
grabs the pawn I let you just move my
love
here comes f3 that's where we want it
Queen h5 is yeah Queen h5 there's if you
can trade on g2 and get 2 HP whether the
car was just finding all the most
accurate defensive moves and he's doing
so quickly now in 83 comes in did he
miss that yep uh we've had two moments
today where I've asked just a question
if I miss something and he immediately
tells us with his facial expressions
that he did
understanding when Takara has blue oh
man the the emotion is real but okay
what's funny is still he still has this
crazy level of compensation and he's
still up on the clock it's just I say
it's hilarious but it's not it's not
funny
yeah it's evil it's evil Nakamura Wow
yeah he just laughs it all blasted off
well struggle with those nights got a
little bit loose loosey-goosey over
there so yeah
all right well LaVon strikes the the 6th
game lead not impossible right you have
his probable improbable especially
because of who he's playing right he's
already playing you know I know everyone
says that he car lost a Magnus in this
format for sure but I believed the only
portions were Hikaru beat Magnus at
least the first time around was in was
in Bullitt I don't remember what
happened last year if Magnus
so anyway obviously Bullitt Hikaru is
he's just just kind of good just look at
the clock he's a minute in seven seconds
they have repeated this position a
number of times though so I think LaVon
it's hard to criticize because you are
playing a card and I've lost so many
games the car that what's going on cars
blundered Bishop he did he did uh two in
a row two games in a row right all right
well I mean not yet remember I called I
called a win versus a car when I want to
rook and Nakara went on to dominate and
crush me the last time we played in the
arena Kings by the way then he talked to
ton of smack to me on slack so just if
you want to be wonder if he does but
he's playing Levon Aronian here and
right yeah I think I don't think Levon
is gonna lose up a piece like I did
though hard to imagine that happening so
let's see that F pawn is also pretty
good what's the way to knock out here
because you don't want a lot of this
game go on too long sort of worrying am
i oh that can't take on g4 cos work
takes the a check yeah just trading nice
little maneuver making it easy on
himself Levon as
yeah there goes the epon Derek here it
goes my Eddie the Eagle wants to wants
to become Ellen on e8o is it garbageman
losing time
yeah well he's taking his time he's
gonna kind of make sure he puts himself
in a smart position it which is it's
just good from an insurance perspective
because wait there's mate he plays it
out to mate I love it
the the thing about Hikaru is he
understands the match strategy Robert
and that if he was gonna go on tilt he
doesn't want to give LaVon a chance to
beat him in the match right so he's
gonna take as much time as he can off
the total clock here to even to ensure
that even if LaVon rattles off four wins
right now still super difficult to come
back so and it's funny because normally
if he would say oh just resign you know
all right off but it's good gamesmanship
I think yeah it's part of the it's like
you could it's like yelling at an NBA
player for dribbling and using the shot
clock when they're up on time I'm sorry
when they're up on the scoreboard right
right
shoutout to kitty kitty hiss hiss we
love you buddy thanks for being here
haven't seen you in a while
appreciate all your support you know
what I haven't seen in a while what is a
card knocking we're losing a mini match
a bullet he's not two and a half one
after the boat right he's actually down
in the bullet portion which is crazy if
you're if you're a new viewer here
twenty one thousand of you make sure you
hit that follow button before you don't
go anywhere the finals is tomorrow the
championship will feature Wesley so
versus the winner of today's match which
we can't call it yet right five games
has been overcoming bold before maybe
not with 16 minutes but LaVon is not not
out of it yet
someone just called him LeBron oh yeah
LeBron Aronian I love that right okay
but live doing well with the black
pieces here is this setup where looks a
little bit threatening or the Queen and
rook on the King side for white but your
pawn structure e 6 f 7 g 6 he keeps it
very solid in fact that white pawn
structure is worse and white is down
upon yeah we did you a quick pawn count
so wait there might be some sacrifice on
e6 you have to consider it eggs H oh
wait just losing oh nice because he
started if H takes it would be a you
know you losing
- Pawnee six anyway you just sacrifice
they went to this end game where black
is better that is yeah that's really
that's like especially to come up with
that I don't know it was a shocking move
but a very interesting idea he owns the
D file he's got a better pollen
structure as you were highlighting the
problem is is Ellen over here reaching
the good move though if you trade own f3
then the bishops dominates yeah that
King said that's routine when the bishop
own scores like this
52 immediately ok b5 awesome yeah if
east six has ever played Black has king
of six so LaVon is not worried about
that
rook d2 now and again if east six okay
he goes up to the pawn but look out
you don't yeah yeah yeah get your King
on a dark square in a hurry seven a key
six when that pawn wait you can't take C
3 because fish for five check to if I
was falling he five is falling
take that Olympus has fallen the coral
might be losing what's he thinking much
take the pawn what is he think oh no
wait won't treat your great Bishop oh
yeah Bishop back at least now you take
the pawn it's even worse for ya I don't
understand high five
why the one did that let's see what's he
going for here in the rook inning I
don't know
take it on d1 and go a for taking on do
you want to go in for I like it yeah
because King if I would never t5 checks
all the way to a2 a3 and a2 LaVon what
about a 383 now and have rook over but
he's still trading I feel like the wrong
pawn yeah it's not easy here obviously
he's under time pressure and it's not
easy playing at karo I mean just
ridiculous to see the time difference
here but but it still feels like like
almost like he over thought that one a
little bit but here was King e6 to d5
and pushed that C pawn king c4 first
know he had King c4 you're right cut the
king that was the difference in c4 would
have been uh he's still trying to work
the King around now you got to the F
file no he's still trying to work the
Queen side Brooke c7 okay and Chris talk
about going King d5 UN now rook F 75455
and he can work his way in but here
comes c4 and kingi for c4 he has winning
Chancellor do it
I don't know why he's taking so long but
yeah he's getting him say it under sir
you okay for the road fighting game g5
yep Wow Cena the car is so car rated now
what am i doing what am i doing wow I
mean everything I've never seen him lose
so many games and bullet in a row yeah
like I've seen Hikaru lose several games
in Bullitt obviously pretty much only to
Magnus in these formats but this is
ridiculous
Wow four-game lead I am I mean I'm
shocked that this is what's happening I
would have expected the lead to be in a
car was favor but him winning all the
bullets then you ask the question you
said what if LaVon just surprises us and
in a monster a bullet right you asked he
maybe you maybe you set this thing in
motion with a question that the universe
was waiting for I'm very surprised like
when is my wife gonna let me get a dog
is d5 another youniverse question d5
them I think I'd be a good dad to a dog
what she won't let the dogs out that's
why we are losing a piece here deflower
just who's he feii gosh LaVon what
Hikaru Hikaru said this yesterday when
young Chris stuff started well he
already said you know the tilt is real
in these formats because you don't have
time to take a break to emotionally
gather yourself yeah and and Hikaru is
is on a bit of a tilt here huge tilt and
I give love wins this he's plus three in
the bullet on down three points of the
match and this is unbelievable stuff
Queen defy would have traded the Queen's
in the spot so that was a missed
opportunity for LaVon LaVon still still
winning though I'm straight of peace
here
a three-game lead with ten minutes to go
if he can win this the next few minutes
is not insurmountable yeah hey Cara
we'll have to win a game to fend off to
come back and right now take a right now
it just seems very straight forward for
LaVon to win this one again he has the
night coming II won mr. tasty fours met
by Bishop D 555 invisible Queen a 424
Queen 40s back in it oh no
Oh LaVon never looks better b3 no be
through Queen e1
oh my gosh I was just spying it I was
like oh oh wow mean a1 and black has
turned it around that was the game that
had caught or not come or needed to slow
down the LaVon train Queen d2 is just
devastating okay - I wasn't expecting as
much but still good yeah yeah the
problem is now tonight if for comes
you're just in trouble here
oh wow wow that is some turnaround
heartbreaking right there I mean
seriously
hey I okay he's doing this on purpose
then the Kings on e - again that's just
disrespectful my opinion he did it again
yep well maybe he's got a a little
system worked out but here now lavon's
coming after him and Vaughn just clearly
angry yeah fresh I would be angry too if
my opponent played against me
yep because objectively it's just not
good chess right to put your king on E -
and then hand Castle just feels like
blacks should have some sort of clear
way to just punish this he's gonna take
on d4 next any forward point 64 mean d5
55 coming back to f5 coming I take on
both those moves are good though I mean
you can put the knight on f5 bring the
other Knight to e7 ooh there's Queen d5
not bad at all either right now after
he's just pinned trades brings the
knight in F force falling tonight g3 but
I don't I didn't like 95 it was a bad
move
yeah you should have taken enough 3 into
Gandhi for it just take that now can you
take a 3 in her missile can yeah yeah he
does okay so what's the piece count even
number of pawns yeah black flecks in
good shape in the endgame but now kingi
- Brooke f8 oh he's giving it to him Wow
rook on age 6 but he went to go GF
guarding the c6 pawn already pretty
awesome this is a very weird game yeah I
mean well it starts weird when your
opponent plays King you - so well you
see a car his face he's like so shocked
by something yeah I don't know what's
happening here I'm just surprised with
everything kingi to second that lat that
last game is still a hangover for me yes
that he LaVon had a win I mean that win
would have brought us to a three game
lead instead we're back to five that was
a very critical moment because car was
kind of on tilt he was he was tilting
the the hype was real the tilt was real
the hype is real for chess Bay before
thank you so much you're winning a car
is up talking wine you were before
before it
he missed before just winning now he's
not winning well and he still get before
yeah but the problem differences the
Brooke wasn't c7 with yes that's what he
that's why he smacked himself in the
face like what am i doing but is yeah
you're just a before before yes you the
point is you can't take on yeah when the
Brooke wasn't b7 you couldn't take him
before cuz then I would've gonna Queen
yeah so black is like it's funny I'll
probably just sit yeah play tickle and
Rob not Robert her car was gonna let
this one tick out take time off the
clock car is very upset about something
well I think he knows he missed before
like you said it was a win and I would
have really put the nail in the coffin
now there's still this outside puncher's
chance although again if you're just
joining us LaVon won three games in a
row and was on the verge of winning a
fourth game in a row and bullet the
score was three and a half one and a
half and LaVon lost the last game so
just a huge win for a car to push the
lead back to five as LaVon was trying to
stage a comeback and yeah and thank you
to SCV ready for gifting some subs I've
seen you do that a couple times here
handful so thank you for that SCV red
he's got Van Pelt
SCV no I don't know what's going on here
coal cars lose weight George's blended
it
g3 and h2 and he's just lost well now h2
th 1 and then drove b2 or something yeah
just bring the king in yeah it is frozen
oh my gosh he thought he could do
whatever he wanted and yeah
okay well again if LaVon have one
Damascus
if LaVon had won the last game and this
game you're talking about a two-game
match yeah Wow
also I think someone named Christoph
just subscribe so maybe yeah either
that's just their name or their yawn
Christophe du de Young Christophe Duda
maybe is d JK d d JK d if Jean
Christophe Judah and jean-claude Van
Damme had a baby what would it be named
good question question C Drive c4 before
d3 these rumors are easy to predict when
it's so winning yep each one Queen a
tween is on the board it's a possibility
for a little bit now yeah okay and now a
car was gonna finally let his time run
out no he's not he's gonna play it to
mate he's milking the clock right now
and and maybe levanto made him in like a
really cute fashion here with all the
ladies if king e5 it was made one on
Queenie one so he avoided it why didn't
she one was better but okay
maybe the Vaughan is now gonna find his
own funny mate maybe he just feels like
the match is lost so he's just gonna be
yeah he's gonna do his own funny mate
hope so
okay well hey Karl lets himself lets
himself lose on time and we're
witnessing the equivalent of chest
rolling right now a little bit but also
a little bit of just gamesmanship not
sure why the game hasn't started yet
yeah next game maybe LaVon doesn't know
that the there's still time left
I think he Caro has rematched but not
sure we can we will
we'll get the game to start here in just
a second there we go there we go okay
sure we'll make the necessary time back
on the clock
ya know it's pretty normal alright well
we we have yet at least one more game
here if LaVon wins again the match gets
closer and you know as much as it it
maybe you think it doesn't totally
matter in terms of whether Hikaru
okay it's gonna be very hard for him to
lose now we're being totally honest four
games with five minutes to play but
every one of these games is worth about
like $300 like seriously because if you
mind if you remember the price for Matt
yesterday Wesley so one more than $5,000
based on a dominant performance of 22 7
right and so every one of these games
the format is that there's a base price
for the winner and the loser and then
every game is worth a certain amount of
money as every round goes on so these
these final four matches there's more
than $12,000 in just those and like just
the the two matches so anyway low it is
it's not like these guys are hurting and
they do well when they play chess but
obviously from a blitz perspective and
the fact that you're kind of playing for
a few hours then you know a few hundred
bucks you can wear whatever a car is
wearing and play on this yeah you can
wear whatever I'm wearing down low means
Oh party up top no party down low
business up top yeah look better for
white a few movies go but at this point
actually there's under four minutes
remaining in the match so even if I were
to lose this one he could just let
himself losing time every other game and
uh that's where he's not gonna lose it I
think he's very committed to winning in
the bullet in particular so he needs to
come back for his own sort of ocean
well-being yeah well he's played well on
the bullet I mean to be honest
LaVon has played very well in the bullet
portion but this King e27 I'm not gonna
be able to get over that the bonk loud
trolling just I don't know especially
you're already winning in the match so
you're kind of feels well it almost it
almost backfired I mean the Vaughn was a
win away from it being a two-game lead
right now the wrong way and I get it
like you know you're winning and you
just want to flex for the audience but
something about it just I think it's I
think it's a twitching but I think he
thinks it's in good fun but we'll see I
mean obviously we'll ask the players how
they feel about it
[Music]
but right now this is a game that
oh wait Bishop no Bishop - excuse me not
possible rook hanging with Chuck
yeah it's good way to get counterplay
the pawn g7 is a target yeah actually
white that's a bone cloud as the name of
that opening I have no I already told ya
I just looked it up
yeah he's the chat begged him to play
bankai that's why he did it
oh really yeah yeah okay so he's clearly
reading the chat well I was like I was
very confused when anyone said bomb
clouds not know it's an actual opening
yeah they were asking him to do it no I
know I get that didn't get the time yeah
okay so anyway this end game somehow
lavon's up the pawns getting lost so
it's gonna be wrong but SCV thank you so
much man you're just going nuts and
throwing on the love and we appreciate
it and yep it's been a it's been a long
month and a long couple matches here but
we are bringing this thing to a close on
Sunday as far as all the chests that
you've seen from the World Chess
Championship leading up to in many ways
chest coms championship here the speech
chess championship on a chess in the
chat out to honor good to have you back
yeah
great coverage over there with you did
the excited to have honor back as we get
prepared for the protest League coming
up though and there you go the car
Nakamura will be playing in the Pro
chess league of course for the Seattle
sluggers and he goes board again
I mean he's playing to the crowd gotta
give him some respect for that I guess I
didn't realize exactly why he was doing
it because as know now we know now we
know but okay he's I'm hoping LaVon gets
this one me too
like and maybe even in crushing fashion
just a lake house loud to help the chat
know that the bond cloud is not a solid
opening but okay we've got a got Magnus
Carlsen hanging out in the chat how is
he first so many of you have been is
still here so thank you for being here
the match is officially coming to an end
in 30 seconds but this game does count
toward the total score so this last game
is probably worth about 250 turn
five bucks so you know the nice dinner
and we're gonna be joined oh by the
players for interviews so don't go
anywhere we will obviously get all of
their thoughts on on what happened here
today and get a car in our cameras
thoughts on facing Wesley so in the
championship which will be tomorrow at
noon pacific so don't go anywhere
look at the views coming right up
playing this game he has to win this one
yep it was night see - I guess you take
it I had oh man
players have been informed that this is
the last game they now know so
impressive honestly that look Hikaru
Nakamura can play this crazy bad opening
and Bend off a gym of Levon Aronian
caliber a super grand master oh there
when g6 all of a sudden lavon's
positions looking worse yeah hey Carl
working the cloud fans will be I like
that move though now have three back
when I'm through then there's the other
rook is coming in on the C file here at
some point way he gets it but there's no
follow-up and if look how hard this is
for black if you take g5 Knight takes e5
is just over and if you don't take g5
then the h6 pawn is falling so maybe you
have to keep the rooks on the G file
yeah I thought he might double on the
second rank there instead of rook c3 the
promise done in the second ranked didn't
have a concrete threats yes so Brooke C
ones coming anyway and here comes c8 as
a problem and anyone think are Nakamura
wins the final game here of the speech
Chess Championship and we have closure
on who will be playing in the finals we
will get closure on this day being
joined by both of these amazing players
here in just a few seconds so don't go
anywhere be right back
[Music]
and we are back thank you everybody that
is with us right now we're at peak
viewership so you guys tuned in to a
very exciting match and now we get to
have interviews with these players LaVon
I guess we'll start with you you you
were putting together quite the run
there in the bullet portion and we we
thought we might be in store for an epic
comeback that the one game that got away
from you did is this like a secret LaVon
thing are you are you just a secret
bullet monster waiting in the wings no
the thing is that the fate of the match
was already decided so yeah that that
explains why I was doing well in the
bullet you know the pressures of you
have already shown your real strength
well it seemed like in the in the blitz
there was just a lot of games that were
that were close and could have gone
either way but then you were you were
just consistently down on time and is
that just the that's just a side effect
of playing hikaru and in blitz where
he's just so fast playing please yeah I
rarely play blitz so yeah that's the
explanation I guess yeah in a car of
course you're very customed to playing
let's you've been streaming a lot so
what was your preparation like for this
match against Levon I mean for me the
match came down really relevant black
and I think he kind of wondered he
probably was winning at some point when
he didn't win that and then he didn't
win the following game this Italian
where it looked like he was beating me I
mean I think after I was well live on
that note then what did you did you also
prepare that Italian or was that just
something you kind of fell into you and
Hikaru guessed right you you had a lot
of very very close attacks that just I
couldn't quite be finished off I had
some knowledge since that please
myself right I'm not that break the play
chief I on a regular basis so so I
wasn't that familiar with those
positions yes therefore quite badly I
handled the medley
speaking of brave choices of car can you
tell us about what you're wearing
because a lot of people chat wanted to
know about your outfit the turtleneck
and the plaid like what's going on it's
cold it's cold here in Italy I kind of
had to yeah I mean got you gotta wear
warm clothes if it's cold so why not
figure dress in style try to try to play
like I'm in style and seem to work out
yeah well you know really appreciate you
guys joining us we know it's a roller
coaster of these things several hours of
Blitzen bullet and then then got to
answer our silly questions but love you
had a great speech Chess Championship
this year making it a semi finals and
obviously we'll be excited to have you
back Hikaru looking ahead you have
Wesley so you've you've done well
against Wesley in this format in the
past as wisely as Wesley said yesterday
but what did you see from Wesley
yesterday against Judah and what are
your thoughts on on that matchup
tomorrow yeah I put what I think I
played Wesley once already in the speech
as champion for me was the death matches
at the time and I beaten that Wesley
played quite well against young Christos
I think maybe you guys because you put
him at 44% to win the match I'm out
though so maybe if you guys put it at
10% he's gonna be super motivated to
beat me yeah Wesley is Wesley played
quite well yesterday I mean I felt that
he was very stable throughout that's
been his strength where is he on
Christos kind of he just went on this
massive tilt and when you tilt bad
things happen so I'll just try not to
tilt maybe play some play some blonde
cloud if I get the chance tomorrow
obviously I think people in my channel
they saw me it's friends for Nissan I
said I would do it so I just had to do
it for chitty chitty hits this and
everyone else just watching so it's
gonna be a fun match and I just looking
forward to playing well because I play
avianna soon so just it's a bit of a
warm-up yeah well thank you both for for
sticking with us answering our questions
and obviously LaVon wish you the best of
luck you're you're traveling to London
right certainly London thoughtfully you
know in a week and hákarl will be there
too and early early just best wishes for
that tournament and we'll see you guys
next year hakarl we will see you
tomorrow
great thank you thanks guys Thanks all
right well those were our competitors
that was I didn't have a lot of
post-match questions sorry if I dropped
the ball no you didn't it just you know
it sort of I like what happens when so
much excitement right hard to come up
with the exact question I think a car is
summed up very well there's that early
game where he discuss where it was
really back and forth he was better than
he was worse and almost missing and he
survived so and I didn't want to ask Lev
a lot of questions when I know I know he
obviously it's hard to lose imagine
you're frustrated and he said he didn't
play well I thought but the quality of
chess was actually very good and Hikaru
kind of resourceful he swindled his way
out of a few games and then also Lev
just consistently down on time it just
goes to show what a car does you know
LaVon said as much right playing a card
Nakamura he just gets a head on the
clock and the position is still very
tough so you don't have time to figure
it out in a car right his credit played
exceptional chess today yeah well
obviously it's it's not over yet for all
of you the fans or for us tomorrow we
have the finals so we will have
grandmaster acara Nakamura taking on
Grandmaster Wesley so they are the last
two men standing in our bracket and we
will have the call for that at 12 noon
pacific time so make sure you give us a
follow before you go anywhere so you get
an alert and we will see you then again
thanks to everybody all the subs all the
crazy just generosity and all the love
that was coming there as CV and
everybody else who was sorry I'm
forgetting everyone's names but just
thank you so much thank you to all of
our members over at the chest comm TV
chat as well and we will see you guys in
in less than 24 hours
[Music]